60 is the safe zone
oh oh oh oh domestic
violence with mark rylance watching
silence
dude with andrew garfield who was
just on a hoop episode we watched oh my
god doctor who are we live
did it happen can you guys hear us we're
at a hundo
we're at a hundo as as according to
streamlabs who's been talking in the
chat with you so we see anissa in the
chat
of course tina thanks for the shirt
anissa check out this cool shirt she got
me
the niece's shirt day and then we have
uh we've got
tms aussie maverick
darth yoda the whipster hillary b
lana pico scarlett's sick
m of course um i think we're live
where's the youtube channel it should
seem as though we are
live bring up that
greg will be nice and respectful to john
that is oh damn i made the wrong graphic
then
it says we're live it says we're live we
can't we don't have anything oh there we
go
yeah we totally got a little giant
update all of a sudden youtube just
caught up immediately
okay let's jump to let's see here
gabriel 19 we are
live can you believe it jean jeter tv
derek mitchell what's going on buddy
joel mayberry
hello mayberry hello there
hello there let's get a little pop-out
going gen v
garzana muhammad
oh my god john you're so sexy at how you
handle it
i do what i'm so sexy at how you handle
this guys it's october
it's hard and half the country had a
interesting october 1st
let's say that let's keep it golly keep
it nice
good golly it's been a great october so
far
especially in america it's been an
interesting october mm-hmm this whitey
night
is in the chat saying hey guys
came across you by accident one day and
haven't stopped watching you since keep
up the good work
oh most people have come across those
backs and i don't think anyone's
been like i'm looking for a channel a
that stars an indian looking guy and an
albino
and here we are here to solve your
dreams for you
i've been searching yeah that's what i
wanted somebody i've been searching far
and wide for your channel
you came to me in a dream michael be in
the chat
oh all right guys well it's hey ricky
how you doing
jockey emily that's so sweet of you we
love your videos
oh i have not seen this sweet uh yes yes
kim wexler i have seen let me in that is
uh i wouldn't put it on one of my
favorite i i had
i was really going back and forth on
what today's topic should be what we
want to do
a couple things i like to give a heads
up about before we just hop straight
completely into this live stream
one is um we are going to slowly be
making a transition to twitch uh for the
live streams in general
talked to too many people in youtube who
are way more popular than us
who have talked about the live stream
problems that present itself
with algorithm stuff yeah oh which
everyone's always telling me
new things about algorithm and how
algorithms [ __ ] up
i'm like i i don't know i feel like some
people are fine when they go live and
they
have great their algorithm seems to be
a-okay but
everyone's been pretty much a common
consensus is
go to uh is like should do a hybrid of
twitch in some way
um they're gonna be exclusively on
spotify actually we got a 100 million
dollar
buyout very excited about that we are
logic and the
other thing um oh hillary b i just saw
her super chat
hello we'll get to it in a second but
get some sleep hillary
and then uh the other thing that i
wanted to mention what was the other
thing i wanted to mention i had another
thing
oh well let me tell you what that was
going to be you know my mind don't you
um we were talking about the the theme
what was it john i mean we were talking
about like what
how we arrived or how you were like what
different things you wanted to talk
about during october and stuff like that
it's okay john you're perfect
we wanted to do um i'm sorry john i'm
being polite you were about to say
something
you just know how to make me feel
special inside that's all okay
okay yes and so
my uh yeah we were like uh do we want to
do
you know over an underrated horror movie
oh that's what i want to say i got it
okay i remember it perfect perfect is uh
for every live stream this month will be
something kind of horror related in some
way
uh that's what we want to do favorite
murder john john our
our favorite john one of our i know your
favorite genre generally speaking
and one and one of my top favorite
genres is undoubtedly horror
and uh so yeah i mean using halloween as
an excuse to talk more about it that
would be great
no this is pre-recorded this is all
pre-recorded i just was able to tell the
same few people who would be in this
live stream today so it was like no
problem
we were really good at anticipating
super chats yeah
we really know who's gonna be in here
yeah super chats and the stream labs as
well just just to give that a
quick plug if you uh wanna either
anything and everything is appreciated
but uh streamlabs takes a little less
so if you don't wanna send money to the
youtube man
uh just keep that in mind but john
john what let's kick this off guys
all right so what do we got in the chat
and then what i've seen a lot of you
guys have already contributed to the
super chats
and also i think one or two in our
stream lab which we really appreciate
yeah but let's see what's going on in
just the the chat itself right now
okay tm does not like horror thank you
for tuning in today
kim wexler saying the first her my her
first is
paranormal activity i think that is a
perfect halloween movie to kick it off i
think the movie gets a bad rap kim
wexler
i think so it gets an unfair bad rep i
gotta say
i think it was very effective i remember
being i don't know if you guys had this
experience
but i remember being in the theaters for
paranormal activity
um and then uh the person i was with at
the time actually threw up
during it but that's not what i want to
talk about so it really annoyed me to be
honest i was like would you
cut this [ __ ] we're in a movie theater
bring a bag with you next time if you're
gonna like
this is embarrassing so no what happened
was
being in the movie theater no one knew
anything about the movie
that was the definition of a word of
mouth film
paranormal activity oh yeah i mean that
was the one where like it was demanded
to come to your city and i i was so late
to that party i saw it at the end of its
la theatrical run
alone yeah in a theater yeah man so that
was a cool experience and yeah i feel
like that franchise gets a bad
rap i think i think the film itself is i
i think it's good still
i wonder if it holds up i haven't seen
it since
since i rewatched it to go into
paranormal activity too
no so i actually don't know if the movie
holds up
well we should rewatch it at some point
do like a re-review
that'd be great yeah i see mark leach
calling out frailty
bill paxton a directed horror movie
which is one i've been meaning to watch
and i i
hear a lot of people name check it so
yeah must be pretty good
um let's see here hey hey
zombiegamer2006 what's going on friend
yo yo uh ricky in the chat is saying
blair witch scared the [ __ ] out of me
it was yours if today's theme was over
and underrated
blair witch would undoubtedly be that my
personal
top overrated top five over and outstand
that movie
nope not a fan not a fan now i just want
to see what happens when you get into a
fight with somebody who shares the exact
same opinion but for the first
paranormal activity
yeah and then you guys can duke it out
as to which you know proto found footage
movie is truly the good one
oh emily in the chat right now is saying
um hers isn't
may the lord jesus and muhammad
bless you covenant all the sins you have
committed john
john is not something
let's not it's not something we're gonna
it's not real every once in a while i'm
gonna
i'm gonna catch myself midway from
making a certain joke
and you're gonna be like what joke does
he want to make a joke of who does he
want to make a joke about but then he's
going to you're going to see greg stop
himself
oh and you guys are going to know who it
is i'm joking about
[Music]
you i think you already knew decoded in
the comments um
but no the uh insidious oh yeah it was
the movie you really recommended to me
that movie scared me from the very first
moment yeah just that [ __ ] credit
that's that that scary ass music and
right away i was like ah
[ __ ] i'm going to be terrified i just i
just
knew it from that opening credit
sequence yeah
was just a title smash i think it's just
the title smash because he has those
shrill
violins and just the spiky word in red
very very good call yeah tc warrior 24 8
0. welcome to the chat my friend
oh i was going to see some love for
zombieland in here
uh i'm everywhere [ __ ] a fan from the
philippines pinoy pride
yes pinoy pride nothing makes
nothing makes me happier when i bump
into a fellow filipino
i've never had a filipino girl recognize
me ever
but it's a damn shame where are my
fellows
man every time i go to little caesars
they're never there
you got to widen out your search
filipinos
little caesars it's either it's either
filipino food or little caesars
um whenever i go i wonder how loud it is
when we yell into our mics for these
jokes
so the um the the what we're talking
about
pinoys uh yes filipinos when whenever i
get recognized by a filipino
person a fellow filipino person and they
don't know i'm filipino but
like greg big fan of your channel blah
blah blah i'd suck your dick you know
whatever they say
i'm always like yeah man i could always
tell when someone's philip not always
but 99.999 percent of the time i can
tell if someone's filipino so i usually
ask you filipino
and i go yeah how'd you know i'm like
i'm half filipino myself and they're
it's the most
exciting and relatability i ever
experienced with
a supporter of the channel whenever
whenever she's i do that there it's the
same reaction every time
they freak out and it's uh it really is
joy for me
pin pin pinoy joy
yeah dude welcome mama's geeky first
live stream
welcome and the fact that you muted
svengoolie to be here i don't know if i
would do the same thing i mean
spengly is is terrific yeah
nightshade holloway oh you got a great
one you know if there's one in the chat
that i want to really
if people if you guys say something i'm
going to pro i got a pen ready
a pen i hold up a notepad oh my gosh
the stupidity jokes just don't stop but
i'm writing one down right now
really uh yeah yeah and nisa
thank you cinema gorilla what's going on
buddy daily dose of chicken strips how
you doing
hey um is pretty creepy that's a good
call
creep show is another good one i saw a
candy man
i did see we did see the new boys
episode it is being edited right now
and uh we'll be up tomorrow to spend two
hours making the thumbnail
man we just gotta go back to we got we
gotta look at what other reactors do for
thumbnails
just blow up one big picture cut us out
put us in the bottom right
corner well let's just shoot everything
in front of a green screen
we don't even no one's like man what a
[ __ ] great thumbnail like what do we
do
what's the point it doesn't really
change the views what are we doing
with the thumbnails you can probably
count on one hand the amount
of comments about like that thumbnail
but hey i mean you know it's an
underappreciated part of the art
uh let's see here and sarcasm for life
welcome to the chat
it follow you know it follows is still a
movie i haven't seen but i've heard
great things about
curious to hear what you think
definitely because it's one of those
it's one of those ones that uh
some people really do love some people
really hate
so i'm i'm very it's it's an interesting
flick and i really want to hear your
thoughts
genius style is saying i really hope
somebody has mentioned nightmare before
christmas which i find to be such
an interest like it it weirdly does hit
the gap where you could watch it
at halloween or during thanksgiving
period or christmas period you could
really watch it at any
any time sorry from october to december
it hits that perfect it's the
like who in terms of them i i'm just so
impressed with the marketing ploy
of nightmare before christmas because it
works just from halloween to christmas
you know what i mean it's
every year it's perfect it's a great
call so yeah
dude just break it into three episodes
watch one at halloween one at
thanksgiving and the last one at
christmas
yeah that's a great call stretch it out
over 20 minute chunks
viper assassin thanks for being
subscribed for so long chris
uh cavazos it says raw red head wrecked
oh raw head rex is one i need to see
actually dead silence
is a good halloween flick alexander wolf
under
appreciated could be better but i like
that movie a lot
all right so let's kick off a couple of
our own personal ones
uh that we definitely like to watch
during halloween time i'm gonna go with
the most obvious one
because it is undoubtedly my most
favorite one and i've talked about it on
this channel
one too many times it's kind of for me
kind of boring to just bring up again so
i'm going to make it super quick
trick or treat it is the ultimate
halloween
film i hope they do a follow-up to it
one day because i feel like you can do
sequels so i think if you haven't seen
trick or treat
um do yourself a favor rent it
buy it destroy the cubbies do whatever
you got to do to get your hands on it
man cause trick or treat
is undoubtedly one of the best horror
movies
and also easily my favorite halloween
movie
way more than halloween it's a bummer
that hollow
the movie halloween to me it's a bummer
to look john you mind if i tell you why
i think it's a bummer that that movie is
called halloween
because it's not really about halloween
it's about one guy who tends to stalk
the same woman
you know and it's not a halloween movie
to me
just happens to take place around
halloween yet because it's called
halloween
it takes the staple you know it you call
hollow if you say there's a halloween
movie coming out
everyone will think of michael myers
great branding
at the same time though i'm i'm on this
like rare side of the fence
that would be happy with a a movie
that's called halloween
that's not about michael myers but
actually about you know
spooky crazy [ __ ] about uh the event of
halloween then
you sir need to go watch halloween three
season of the witch
yeah i know it turned out great and they
haven't changed the franchise back
since everyone loved it but but i mean
hey olivia
seriously oh yeah vacuum as loud as you
olivia vacuum we got the mics we got
these mics on so you so if
when you vacuum uh it's okay she's not
even listening in fact come and
come in here and vacuum yeah come here
value you'll see the mics won't pick it
up
john which which one do you got which
one you want to tell the folks at home
about that you think
is so damn your halloween joint
oh my goodness well i mean i obviously
agree with you for trick or treat i mean
that is
just just to sidebar really quick that's
what i think one of my favorite
movie going experiences with the time
that we saw that at a random test
screening on november
3rd but um the another one that always
comes to mind and it's not a
feature-length movie but it's not
halloween time until i've seen
it's the great pumpkin charlie brown oh
really that's your
good pick that is one that i have seen
that yeah it's one of those like
you know short but it's like it gets me
fully in the spirit it also gets me
thinking back
to childhood and to youth and also you
know you've got the charlie brown stuff
but then you also have the stuff with
snoopy being the red baron and so you
get some like art and jazz in with your
halloween
and as far as the charlie brown holiday
specials go
it's like that one and the christmas one
or like the gold standards
yeah yeah that and actually what i my
goal this
year is i think they're on the 31st
season the simpsons and one thing i love
to do every halloween season is just
marathon treehouse of horror episodes so
i think this year what i'm going to try
and do is watch all
31 of those i feel like treehouse of
horror from the simpsons is probably the
best halloween thing
yeah because you get three little
stories and there are if we were
including
shows i would say i would definitely say
that one
yeah but we've got we've gotten some
super chats i would like to pick up on
uh here because we've been live for a
little while now
um so let's john can you can you help me
out here
you're so good at doing this you're so
good at fixing it
oh i saw somebody a minute ago uh
shouted out halloweentown
the disney channel originals whipster
keeps saying justice league is pretty
terrifying it's a scary film it's a it's
that mustache am i right oh goodness
that mustache
i've never seen such a nightmare
hey look we got some super chats here
let's go down to the first one from
october the three already carissa in the
chat is saying that she's just
subscribed to
uh disney plus for treehouse of horror
primarily
that's probably perfect i'm honestly
surprised disney plus
allows treehouse a horror it is pretty
violent yeah it's bloody very violent
there's some
gore in those episodes i mean shocks me
there's whimsy but yeah
it it certainly seems on the edge of
disney's uh acceptability
um one second let me let's do something
with my phone real quick
here some phone action on you uh do some
phone stuff
okay cool all good anissa all right all
right
so let me let me see here all right john
you got this
yeah just got this john a little further
so we could see what the agoraphobic
fanboy has to say
first tipper of the day thank you so
much for your contribution
uh hey love your hosting voice oh thanks
i love it
agoraphobic fanboy the first tipper of
the day oh
i pitched everything up into my nose oh
this is where we're live
and we're we gotta keep talking to my
head my energy in the audience
i've heard it said that head voices make
people feel more energetic
anyway now let's let's go to npr thanks
for dropping in here at kabu
so uh guys boys will be tomorrow
in the morning sunday sunday boys so the
agoraphobic fanboy
what's he say he says hey guys
casper1995
just did a video review of this holds up
well and has a great
saturn game sega remember the toys
amazing
oh you know i i don't have a huge
recollection of the casper toys but that
film is another one of those staple of
my youth like i just
like memories are burned into my retin
like mind's eye from that film do you
know who played
the villain in the movie um
john you oh kerrigan or whatever her
name is oh i thought you know i thought
you had it i thought you had it
does anybody know who played the villain
in that movie no
yeah i met her once um and she starred
with robert de niro
in a black and white movie oh raging
bull
yeah oh damn you got it you got her name
she's raging blue
she's raging bull that's right that's
what they called her on saturday raging
bull
that's the wasn't even the film's title
kathy barrard moriarty um
moriarty marietti i can't even say aaron
moriarty from the boys
uh but casper i love
yeah i love that movie i think i
i feel like that's a bit of an
underrated gem that is and i would say
it's a and it's a perfect
call for halloween that doesn't always
get brought up it
that is true that's a fun it's not scary
at all
but it's a great like it's got it's got
a good heart man it's got a great heart
bill pullman who always kind of creeped
me out i don't know what it is about
bill pullman i get it
that the dad in the movie you could see
him being an untrustworthy uncle
i can see him having some like weird sex
tape
yeah i don't know why him and him and
like bill pullman that just
creeps me out and i can't pinpoint i
feel like i'd see he and colin farrell
on a sex tape together
yeah but the movie itself is moving he's
great he stars clint eastwood mel gibson
um they are in that i don't know if
that people might have stopped forget
about that but
they are in it um yeah i even like the
weird prequel they did
about casper like him suffering in the
hospital for 90 minutes until he dies
and becomes a ghost at the end no they
did a start
hayden christensen they did a prequel to
it of
uh like when he gets to hang out with
the ghost and that i barely remember it
but i remember liking it when i was a
little kid
well yeah it has a fun mixture of like
family
whimsy horror stuff but it's also kind
of gothic like there's a love story
true you know um all right well thank
you agoraphobic fanboy yeah
marcus the leech you could leech off of
us for as long as you want or we'll
leech off of you
ready or not is my it's one of my
favorite
films from the past few years it had
great humor
samara weaving is the latest generation
scream
queen yes i would say
uh tyler slaven noticed the chairs so uh
i would say
that ready or not i feel like will
become more of a cult classic as time
goes
have you seen it yet i haven't it's it's
pretty great it's really impressive and
i
i you know i would venture to say i
loved it from beginning to end yeah
buddy
i was really pleasantly surprised by it
and it is intense
it's the trailer gives away an awful lot
but there's still plenty of surprises
that occur in the last half hour
and i think samara weaving is is an
absolute gem you know who
who uh we kind of know someone that we
kind of know who i think could be a
future because he said scream queen i
don't know if samara weaving quite makes
it there
just yet but someone who i do can see
being a future scream queen and someone
who we kind of know
um alex esso um from
she she did uh starry eyes and
she was also the mom she she was the mom
in uh
who was the [ __ ] my god my my dialogue
today is so on point
the mother and doctor sleep though hello
i'm shelley duvall
yeah yeah she's a replacement for shelly
duvall that was her and she's done a lot
of other horror movies and i could see
her being a future scream queen just
knowing she's done like cons for horror
and stuff
because she she does she books a lot of
horror films and she has a lot of great
depth and she's sure if you guys know
her but she's great
yeah yeah definitely like keep an eye
out for her in future projects because
she is a terrific performer yeah
and uh like how ricky just pointed out
in the live stream uh
for ready or not those directors are
making the next scream movie
and if i didn't love scream so we should
just have a graphic on screen that says
if you guys haven't noticed the boys
generally goes up on saturday
on sunday the boys goes up on stage let
me make a new graph
because we like to give people time to
watch the show
and and then i know some we probably get
better views or something
if we did that before but at the same
time it does i prefer people watch the
show and they can come to us just so
they mainly focus on the reaction yeah
anyway so uh if i didn't love ready or
not so much and
i i did find scream fork i didn't really
like that movie uh i liked it a lot the
first time i liked it significantly less
the second time
so i'm not as perturbed by the idea that
they're continuing it without wes craven
i know that's not the proper thing to
say
but the because the directors of ready
or not
are behind it i would say that i'm much
more
excited for uh scream five and what they
might have to offer i feel like they
could bring something very fresh
very reinvigorating for screen five and
speaking of halloween i mean
judging by their segment in vhs alone
like that also gets me excited like
anything
i got to see ready or not but radio
silence that team is really creative it
seems definitely
see john you know we're talking about
it's it's spooky days this is my it's my
days carter lovejoy wouldn't be a live
stream
without without having carter lovejoy
appear in our chats thank you so much
carter
uh and he he actually i see him in the
chat right now saying so excited for the
ready or not duo to direct stream and
his super chat says
my favorite movie to watch around
halloween is the first scream
now scream even though i listed trick or
treat
as my my favorite um movie to watch
to get me in the halloween spirit scream
is undoubtedly my
undoubtedly my favorite horror movie i
put screaming
you know after re-watching hereditary i
think i got screaming hereditary at my
top
yeah hereditary i really do love and um
i think and scream though for sure is my
is my
it's still number one to me it's it's
really hard to top scream for me
um we're a screen rank for you in horror
movies john i don't think you've ever i
don't think it's your favorite but where
does it rank for you
it's definitely one of the one of the
ones that i've grown
greater and greater appreciation for
over the years like yeah
i think i missed it at the time that it
came out and it's one
yeah that i think i would love to do
another proper re-watch on again because
i have a pretty decent recollection of
screams seeing all the screen movies now
thanks to
you know watching the fourth one
recently but uh yeah like that movie
feels like a special kind of lightning
in a bottle
it feels like you know the perfect
like i'm very curious as to how they're
gonna do a scream
five especially on the heels of the
screen four because that movie
represents a perfect moment in the 90s
where the voice
of that decade found a genre that was
kind of
ailing and made something so special out
of it that still echoes today
and yeah i mean like friggin clipping
just dropped a song called 96 nev
campbell like
she is one of them like
in this newer era once you get past the
80s she is like
the final girl you know i think
uh she was my first celebrity crush nev
campbell
yeah and uh yeah it was your first
celebrity group and i
i yeah yeah i was just i agree i was
obsessed with her
no no no no it wasn't her yeah wait it
might have been
when did i seek [ __ ] spacek might have
been my first celebrity crush
okay carrie no that was never campbell
who's hotter i think sissy's basic today
is way hotter than young netflix
[Laughter]
fine wines fine wines
no yeah i think you could put them side
by side i think in fact they're gonna
play sisters in scream five
yeah he's the other sister uh thank you
carter lovejoy scuba steve thank you for
the sticker buddy
love you scuba go check out his
instagram page does great stuff
hillary b thank you i'm sorry i have to
go to bed
but um i hope you get some sleep have a
good nightmare i only got about three
hours myself last
night mm-hmm but hey i'm not complaining
we're here today we're doing a restream
this is when we're because we just
wanted to go live
thank you hillary b real quick yeah john
what's your favorite scream sequel
oh too undoubtable i love the scream
franchise in the exact order of release
dates
good i'm glad i'm glad that scream three
is getting screamed
almost a perfect scene like that's like
to me that's
that's how you do a scream too and
scream three kind of bar kind of goes
down a little bit in screen four not so
much
uh but yeah it's scream one is perfect
yeah so yeah
nev campbell though man she still looks
pretty great she does
for 72 years old she doesn't look like
he doesn't look a day over 45
that was the biggest surprise to me
watching scream for i was like wait a
minute she's much older than
most of the cats but i can't tell are
you kidding
you know when that hit me was when i
watched when we watched skyscraper with
dwayne johnson
that's right she's his wife i was like
damn she's too young to be dwayne
johnson's wife oh wait a minute she's
older than she was
age-appropriate somehow damn yeah
go now that's when it happened for me
yes
um mark leach back at it thank you
marcus
says i watch classic horror halloween
night at
cinema i got to see my favorite the
thing
on the big screen what's your favorite
you you
saw at the cinema oh so i'm assuming
we'll redirect this question to be
what's the favorite
horror movie we saw at the cinema
um so first off the thing i know is
probably one of j
is one of john's favorite movies it is
and i've been lucky enough to see it on
a big screen a couple times so fist bump
i'm trying to think of a horror movie
that just had me tense from beginning
to end i feel like paranormal activity
really did that for me
yeah drag me to hell drag me to hell oh
great call take it away john tell them
about her
drag me to hell experience so we went
back when we were
doing just test screenings left and
right before we were not allowed to do
that
yeah we got into this yeah i think we
just knew the title and then it was a
sam raimi movie and they were
doing it it was like a year in advance
yeah before there's even a trailer
yeah they were deciding apparently
between an r-rated or a pg-13 rated cut
and we just went because yeah i was like
oh damn sam ruby's coming back to horror
and and i remember the both of us that
that movie
from beginning to end had us just like
jumping and writhing and like
laughing and getting scared all at the
same time and i feel like that
that experience especially that first
time has always stayed with me because i
think it's the most i've ever felt
two simultaneous feelings like that for
such a prolonged amount of time
very true yeah that was a really grippy
i love that experience yeah
like the perfect balance of comedy and
horror for me but michael b in the chat
dimension
uh the grudge and i remembered that was
a horror movie
in the theaters that i saw that haunted
me for a while like everywhere i went
i just kept imagining it and when i was
alone at home i would imagine
the uh not samara uh
yeah but the american version uh yeah
that
that really that was one that haunted me
um when
when i was younger yeah i was the kind
to be influenced by
imagery in a movie and would always be
scared that i would see it at some
corner or something like that that it
would be following me around in some way
i think j-horror is especially good at
doing that yes
yeah but um another one that was a
really scary experience for me that
that was i i feel like has gained some
respect over the years but
i personally thought it was really
haunting when we were watching in the
theaters and i think it's because i
expect this movie to be so bad
and the fact that we were so close to
the screen too
because we were like two rows away from
the screen
was uh the video game adaptation of
silent hill
yeah that surprisingly felt like a
really
haunting bleak experience and i i think
it had something to do with
the combination of being tired and and
being just two to three rows away from
the screen
and that really made it feel like a
terrifying experience so my memory of
silent
oh and sarcasm for life said it 28 days
a week yeah
i was by my sitting by myself as a kid
watching in the theaters and that was a
really
horrific experience i got to tell the
story now tell it i gotta tell the story
um so when i saw 28 days later
it was after church on sunday i saw a
trailer and i told my mom
i want to watch this movie i had no idea
why i wanted to watch it i just wanted
to watch it
um i think i was just bored and then we
went to the theaters
and we got there kind of late trailers
had already started
and and and i i sat i was like i just
got to find a seat because there's no
two seats together and my mom will not
go to a movie unless she
has popcorn and soda so
uh i found a seat by myself i'm like i'm
like 12 or something at this point
you know i'm a little kid and so i i
found a seat by myself
i'm sitting there alone the movie starts
my mom has not come in the theater yet
she's missing the whole thing with the
monkeys at the beginning in the lab
reach and then suddenly you cut to
killian murphy's eyes opening
and then you cut to a naked killian
murphy
with his dick laid out and everything on
screen realism
that's when i see my mom walking to the
theaters
because i didn't have a cell phone back
then
which is an arm full of hot dogs
she walked into the theaters with these
two large popcorns and two large sodas
because you could get deals back then
i just see only her eyes like like a
raccoon like where's my son
and there's a big dick behind me on
screen see i got to have that experience
at home with my mom
yeah so you lucked out she kept
rewinding it your mom
she felt this i didn't know you could
zoom in on dvd you had a repeat button
or you could just loop that scene
yeah i've seen a few people call it
phantasm in here that's a that's a good
one the the pale
my god uh let's see but thank you mark
leach i kept this on for a while there's
a problem
great name from australia poppy
watch don't look now 1973 last night for
the first time a great halloween horror
film much more on the atmospheric than
gory's side but
amazing i appreciate the recommendation
dude add that to the list it's a film
i've heard of
many times and i should see what is that
audrey because you said
70 so it's i appreciate the
recommendation and it's it's reminding
me
of a movie the the audrey hepburn movie
i brought up
where she's blind wait until dark wait
until dark that's an underrated horror
film
and uh it was i was either like late 60s
or early 70s i forget we were arguing
about
texas chainsaw massacre which one came
first yeah and uh
wait until dark is a underrated horror
film from around that era
so yeah don't look now i haven't heard
of this movie but sounds like a great
time thank you yeah andrew about does
got it wait until dark
appreciate you buddy for looking out
boom and i have seen hocus pocus
hocus pocus let me introduce it to me
jenna thanks for asking and they're
going to be revisiting that movie
apparently soon with some kind of
follow up and also yes halloweentown
shouts out to jay paul zimmerman yeah
man
thank you pope yeah i'd love to gulp
your pulp
derrick brown thank you derek brown for
being here buddy i'd like to
down your browns derrick brown's a guy
with the intimidating
canta if you're friendly but you
probably are oh yeah he's gonna
thumbnail pic right here which horror
movie do you think
is the most underrated most underrated
horror movie
out of like drag me to hell and uh
trick or treat no i dragged me to hell
it's definitely it
chapter one man in chapter one what
insidious
pretty underrated um
you know i have a pic that's called
uh the invitation the invitation
is a movie not for everyone
but not in the sense that it's so
disturbing it's not for everyone or
something like that
it's a very deliberately paced movie
that
it just feels like something bad is
gonna happen every second of the film
yeah and and and that it preys on the
uh the anticipation of social anxiety
fears and it's uh it's a great great
horror movie
that and the finale of it just
and the performance by logan marshall
green from upgrade phenomenal yeah i
think the script is beautiful i think
the directing is rock solid
it's all takes place at a house in one
night but it doesn't play out at all how
you'd expect
and it never goes down a conventional
path i think the invitation is actually
on netflix so
if you guys you know have 90 minutes
give it a shot
i think it's absolutely worth it and
it's uh logan marshall green that
doesn't like when we met logan marshall
green
at the upgrade premiere yes um
the first thing i mentioned to him was i
was his work in the invitation
like that his work there just blew my
mind yeah and then i eventually
complimented him on the movie we were
there to see
but uh the invitation is the one for me
that's like a phenomenal performance and
then i pulled him aside for 40 minutes
to talk about devil
yeah which i think is actually an
underrated horror movie but uh the one
that came to
mind go watch the the devil spooky
elevator movie it's good
but uh the one that came to mind when
you said the invitation was oddly
filmed by the same director i don't know
if it's the most underrated horror movie
but
i've liked this movie since the first
time i saw it and only
recently after like 10 years or more is
it finally starting to have that like oh
maybe it's actually pretty good which is
jennifer's body
same director yeah yeah yeah exactly
director two
very very different films totally pacing
everything
very different movies but yeah that was
one i i finally watched and i was like
oh yeah everybody seems like really up
in arms and like really doesn't like
this movie then i watched it i was like
i don't get what y'all saw cause i
thought this was pretty cool
yeah so uh yeah i'd say go give that a
revisit
i'm seeing uh on this question on this
particular question that we're on right
now
there's a horror movie do you think is
the most underrated i'm seeing a lot of
love
for a couple of films that i'm glad are
being cited in the chat
which are red state and fright night now
i haven't seen the original fright night
i haven't seen the remake i'm guilty of
that oh wow you haven't seen the remake
see i saw the remake and i thought the
remake was
awesome i really want to see it i i
thought it was an awesome ass remake
yeah and i thought colin ferrell was
great anton yelchin amazing and
lieutenant i forgot he's peter vincent
yeah
either way man like the the the remake
of fright night i thought
hey i don't think i made any money but
it was really gonna
i personally had a blast with that movie
it was really fun
and uh the other one is uh red state
kevin smith's red state i think both of
the
his two big horror movies that he did
were red state and tusk
i i love both of those films i think
that's
way more my kevin smith cup of tea when
it comes to
his films yeah is his take on horror
comedy his
kooky well not even not even comedy like
there's a sense of humor
especially to tusk but there's more less
of that sense of humor and red state
but you still get that vibe it's that
demented quality
yeah yeah yeah and the descent too but i
feel like the descent is not as
a lot of people are saying to the
descent in the chat i don't think the
descent is
it's like underrated as it once was i
feel like it's got a much bigger
following
yeah we got some sequels i feel like the
descent and
i've seen near dark uh coming up a good
amount and i feel like those movies are
ones that
should probably be wider scene but it
seems like anybody who has seen them
is pretty jazzed about them also ricky
i've heard about the entity
and that sounds like a horrifying movie
about the ghost like assault
i'll see it at some point because i keep
hearing about it but uh
but that seems like a tough one to get
through you're getting a lot of uh
you're getting a lot of support and for
the uh for your call out for jennifer's
body man hey
good call okay underrated all right good
call johnny uh
thank you derek fund me productions
fund me productions you're next
2011 i haven't seen your next your next
is pretty nifty
thank you fun me yeah great channel
mm-hmm um
your next 2011 you've seen your next
yeah yeah you're next is a lot of fun i
mean
you know it's taken it almost reminds me
less less of a film film than like
what an uh knife
less of a celluloid expression
than like ryan johnson's knives out but
for whatever reason it kind of reminds
me of that but if you did that to the
home invasion genre instead
like i don't know if that's in any way
an apt comparison but yeah
uh you're next is a pretty cool twist
and subvert on uh yeah home invasion
movies and actually knowing what i do
know about uh ready or not i feel like
you might appreciate your next
because there's a similar like oh you
know there's an outsider coming to a
family gathering
being nice to maybe all right
i just want to point out that john was
the guy when we were younger who would
give you presents based off of what he
liked
yeah it was advice i was given
that i did not follow the proper driver
away
what do you like give them that yeah i
was like
this is a good starting point but you
also have to kind of tailor it to them
too although john did give me a a pretty
amazing uh
gift for uh my birthday uh just today
that i'll rock sometime next week you
guys will see it
um gosh and make sure to face away from
the camera when you do i think we should
do any videos in between when the boys
episode comes out
and then put out there's so many hitting
comments about the boys right now people
just jumping in they're not us hiding it
it's like a weird though i have to like
click
to make sure they can be yeah anyway my
point is
yeah what's a boys episode drums like
nothing else
everyone sees we're live they're like we
gotta we gotta remind them about the
boys
yeah do you guys know there's a new
episode out um
so let's see here okay i'm beijing guck
she got what you wanted
it's all right uh but thank you wreck
great one captain in the woods classic
wreck
how did how do people feel about
quarantine because it's like the same
movie but wreck has like
infinitely more respect i've seen rec 1
and rec 3
wreck three had an interesting thing
that that i that i stole
for our the sketch that we did uh
akkason's honest interview
was this greg okay okay because rec does
wreck three has this moment because it's
handheld it's it's
captured like found footage still but
then halfway through
to just stop that and they just turned
into an actual movie
is that the wedding one yeah okay okay
yeah yeah it's kind of a weird choice
but the rack movies are pretty good okay
um and
uh i remember
it's called quarantine yeah yes
quarantine
two hmm hey quarantine one is the
most spoilery trailer i've ever seen
yep i'm surprised there's a documentary
coming out that john campia put together
of
about trailers and um i'm i'm sort of in
it
i'm one of the people being interviewed
but i'm not in it that much anyhow
i wish i had cited quarantine because
that is the
most spoiler-filled trailer yeah
everything's from like the last 10
minutes the
money shot of that trailer the money
shot of the trailer that scared everyone
it's the last shot of the money shot of
the film
shot of the movie which undoubtedly
spoils the
outcome of the movie sitting there
waiting for it and then it happens and
you're like oh wait we're not going to
build
beyond that and it's not it the movie is
not
like spider-man amazing spider-man 2.
it's
worse than that they yes they show you
the last shot of amazing spider-man 2
with taking the top of the sewer lid
and swinging it at rhino they do show
you that shot
but it's not really ruining something
it's just more like oh that's just the
last shot and the last shot is the tease
for the sequel
that ending shot of quarantine trailer
shows you the outcome of that character
because if that wasn't the last shot it
could have just been a scene from the
middle of the movie
and then you see what happens and she
gets out but but that last shot
ruins the movie for you yeah cause the
second
the second i remember that because when
it happens there's a moment of black
and then you're like okay someone's
coming right and then the titles start
to roll and you're like oh
what so why yeah man it's [ __ ] up
[ __ ] gotta love advertising mama's geeky
your reaction to the boys was blocked uh
we've gotten a lot of our for for the
people who watch the boys reactions
um there's plenty of moments that have
caught the reason why
they take so long to edit is i i hate
dealing with the blocking process
i don't get a [ __ ] phone call that's
like hey your video was blocked you want
to do something about it like
i might not be by my phone and get an
email i'm like oh [ __ ] i got blood it's
been blocked for hours i didn't even
know
um but but the boys there's so many
times where
like especially with the music it's this
stupidest things we'll get it blocked
five seconds of like barely any music
and so low
that we're talking over it like get the
video blocked
and there's been plenty of times where
like the video will be live for 24 hours
and then suddenly bam this this one like
10 seconds which is usually a big moment
of the show which is a bummer has got it
blocked so i just gotta
i gotta like manually go into youtube
and trim it out of the video it's a
really unfair
it's a really hard thing to work around
yeah it's not very uh uh
you know uploader friendly yes anywho
rosie uh q a post roughly around the
fifth
day of the month so keep your eyes
peeled for that if anybody wants to ask
a question on the patreon
pandemic jones thank you so much pj for
being here my dude loves chatting with
you
peach what's up guys spooky season is
one of my
favorite times of the year likewise some
of my favorite horror movies would be
the shining
get out the witch it 2017
evil dead you know i got a specific
comment i want to make about it
halloween the science of the lambs and
insidious those are all
knockout movies terrific yes you nailed
all different kinds of horror there
great call
um i would actually say that i think
it the miniseries is
more of a halloween vibe like a movie to
watch around halloween
more than the movies than the theatrical
release movies actually
i'm with that uh those have a much more
like campy
spooky they're still like twisted and
weird and the adult part is still
kind of boring but the um i don't know a
chapter two the adult stuff is boring to
me too
so i would say that uh in terms of the
movies versus the mini series
the movies i think are better and
stronger quality
undoubtedly however i would say the mini
series is more of the kind of thing i
would probably put on
during holiday if there was a party
going on i would put on like the the it
mini series versus the it movies
tim curry is more halloween party i
would say oh yeah absolutely
georgie and all those garish colors and
everything
uh i see the mist somebody shouted out i
see the crazies
that's one of my favorite horror movie
remakes right there yeah for sure the
witch
i think is a great call on here as well
uh evil dead witch one
is what i want to know because you could
do like a whole evil dead marathon for
halloween
um the science of lamps of course of
course and by the way guys by the way
uh pandemic joe since you listed the
signs of the lambs i would also say
the uh i i finished the hannibal series
finally
finally finished the hannibal series
quick opinion of it
i think that's a i don't know if it's
like the halloween show to watch
but first season great second season
perfect third season
was real up and down for me really hit
or miss it took me forever to finish the
last two episodes
like like there was the last episode was
spread out over the course of like
three months so yeah uh but
but those are all good picks man thank
you pathetic jones yeah
i think get out is uh it's that was that
was a rare
fleet where it just became like an
instant classic yeah and he won the
oscar for writing and you're like yeah
yeah you [ __ ] earned it yeah
it's not just because it's popular here
you know he held on from
february to a great call he managed to
get an oscar nomination from a february
that's unheard of yeah that's like
unheard of a february movie to get an
oscar winner
it's crazy the remembrance of the
academy is not that long
peter peter thank you pandemic jones
peter pacheco pacheco
new patreon sub here thanks peter
pacheco just called
your name always love your captain
spalding house of a thousand corpses
duh devils rejects three from hell
trick or treat jennifer's body halloween
series
john i think you found your soul mate
buddy we
need to hang out for halloween john is
the
the the defender of that's right
the defender i will die on this oh rob
zombie movies these films are the hill i
will die
every time rob zombie is brought up it's
always mentioned with the
with a caveat of i know he's not
i know nobody likes him except for me
and ten other man
it's johnny let's be my president
explaining his love for rob zombie
and just he always has to have a
pre-face it with i know
people don't but i really love
the first halloween movie he did you
know i mean honestly that
movie puts me in a halloween kind of
vibe and i do watch it every year during
the season rob zombies halloween does it
it does yeah oh wow yeah nope doesn't do
that for me
yeah i don't know exactly i like rob
zombies halloween that movie does not do
that
for me though in terms of the halloween
vibe it feels like
fall and the thing about the way he
captures small
town at halloween time it's weird that
movie
and i know this is going to be blasphemy
more than you
before but like that movie puts me in a
halloween
vibe just for the season more so than
the john carpenter one puts me in the
halloween season five
i would say a house of a thousand
corpses puts me
way more halloween spooky vibe over
rob zombie's own halloween movie i will
totally give you that yeah it's like
that
in fact i that is definitely one of my
like halloween
season films in fact of all the devil's
rejects movies that's the one
for halloween season to me a nissa oliva
does not like rob zombie
sorry to hear that lords of salem
underrated too according to travis
austin in the chats we're on this rob
zombie talk right now i like lords of
salem a lot i mean that's one i would
put
like the same way you would put on the
witch i would put on lords of salem
because that's such an icky
kind of yeah fraught and dreamish
experience
you know what i'm going to meet chris
cavazos uh
i'm going to meet him here i'm going to
agree with him here
uh in the chat he's saying rob zombie
halloween better than the original
i can't i can't say it's better
i'm not allowed to say that i don't know
if i would
i don't know if i would say it's better
however i would say i would
any day of the week put on rob zombies
halloween over john carpenter the first
one
i would say like if we're comparing the
first ones i would much rather watch rob
zombies i find that exceptionally more
entertaining it is my favorite halloween
movie
really no no not film for halloween time
but just of the halloween
films it is my fault oh really i still i
think
the reboot and and part four
is my favorite those are my still my
favorite ones yeah
part four franchise to keep up with uh
oh god
but he listed like all your movies yeah
peter pacheco literally listed
all your trick-or-treat in there
jennifer's body that's pretty bizarre
he is your soul mate now i'm definitely
gonna learn that portuguese access damn
i'm just hey i'm happy that we got to
this point before you know
7pm yes why hasn't rob zombie done
nightmare on elm street
i'm gonna answer your [ __ ] dreams and
[ __ ] kill you you stupid [ __ ] kids
i'm gonna
[ __ ] cut you up i now
want that to happen get walton goggins
to play
freddy and we'll go you know because
frey
you know freddy would make sense in a
rob zombie ma
mad cap fever i gotta say this hands you
dumb [ __ ] here yeah
he's gonna cut the [ __ ] out of you
trailer park trash that's rub zombies
nightmare on home street summed up in
one yeah
one thing hey it would be a thousand
times better than the
the platinum dude that's mine that's my
that's my version of any rob zombie
movie adaptation you want to do
yeah it's pretty much all of them except
maybe lord's
my name's jason voorhees i got a [ __ ]
hockey mask this the first one we're
changing
a lot jason talks more than any other
character
he only killed three people but he
talked a whole bunch
took his mask off
yet we are taking our time it's been a
minute it's been a minute since we've
live stream
a cartoon we have we haven't livestream
in a while uh
kartik sharma thank you so much buddy
how's it going kartik
which non-horror director can pull off a
horror movie
oh what a question that is a great
question
oh i love this question oh i wish i
thought of
stuff before i wish i had a premonition
that this question would come in
um what are some directors that haven't
done
horror that it's weird because it's
usually the opposite yeah i know right
and then once you venture into [ __ ]
you're like what the [ __ ] let's go
krazynski
yeah he's rock what's going on here uh
let's get a denis villeneuve's horror
movie
i feel like he's just a stone's throw
away kind of
sicario is kind of a horror
they have like a horror feel to it all
right all right all right how about
um i feel like the russo brothers could
pull off a fantastic horror movie that
would be fun i think they could do a
great
great they know comedy so they would
know how to alleviate tension and
release pretty well
yeah they would know how to do the
tension and release but they also know
how to make
intensity mm-hmm um non-st i don't know
different versions of the word tense can
i use but they proved yesterday captain
america water soldier
but all their other movies too they know
how to bring intensity to the big screen
and i really think he could do it judas
in the chat is actually saying mel
gibson i think mel gibson could do a
horror movie for sure
um tarantino has already done horror
yeah he's already done horror man people
forget about death proof but that is a
horror movie undoubtedly
an underrated one i'll add to that yes
siree bob
um i love the chat guessing what when we
when we're actually reading the chat
it's hard to read the chat keep up with
the chat
talk to the camera
monday we'll get a moderator but it
actually takes out some of the fun if
we're not moderating ourselves i want to
see a brad bird horror
you know what's funny we haven't heard
anything speaking of this like
non-horror director
category we haven't heard anything about
a quiet place too
at all that's yeah yeah that was one of
the first movies to get postponed
and now it's just on the day just let
that like fly under the radar you know
mm-hmm yeah it's a bummer i hope i mean
we'll see it i feel like they're just
gonna whoever who's releasing that again
they're just gonna sit around until we
really know
yeah man now that like fast and furious
and james bond have already bumped again
you know who else i think could be
direct a great horror movie is
um christopher mcquarrie ooh that'd be
cool
if if he doesn't have tom cruise
christopher mccormack tom
i think he would know how to bring the i
mean he wrote usual suspects
um when his he knows how to i think if
you're someone who knows how to capture
tension and suspense
i feel like you can probably do horror
you know and i feel like that's that's a
great one too
ryan coogler's not a bad pick anthony
manzano said that in the chat ryan
coogler that's it that's actually not a
bad pick
one i mean i don't i don't know no then
i don't know why sylvester state noah
yeah nolan yeah no one would be great i
felt like nolan had already done horror
but now that i'm thinking about it
i think people thought insomnia was
going to be a horror movie but it wasn't
yeah it has that thrillery almost serial
killer quality
definitely more of a thriller
psychological thriller not a horror
movie
so that's the thing like that sometimes
the tones can bleed
because if something feels like
suspenseful and thrilling i can and
admit
a feeling of feeling scared yeah but
that doesn't make it a horror movie you
know
kim wexler said wes anderson that's a
horror movie
the most symmetrically framed horror
movie with the corgis of characters eat
your heart out kubrick
in fact they did an snl uh sketchup guys
in the chat a wes anderson horror movie
at one point
i wanna boots riley horror movies yeah
most like politically disturbing horror
movie
uh thank you card sick that's a great
question eric horseman
horst messaged you back right before we
went live buddy happy to see you again
here
yes siree um you guys got to get an air
b
you bradley and anissa get that airbnb
come on out here
yeah just move out into the airbnb
re-watching
every mike flanagan movie in this order
mike flanagan is a [ __ ] amazing
director
anagrams man i haven't seen absentia
i've seen some oculus i really liked
hush even though
it is apparently very offensive to those
who are hearing
impaired and and we've met pete i
remember
the first time i met your your really
close friend jimmy
yes so first time i met his really close
friend jimmy
and john is not the type to bring me
around his friends
i'm like that that the significant other
we're like why don't you want me to meet
your friends oh
you know so you're right he really
rarely does right i know it's not me
it's
the thing that you have that you you
have to get over
yeah so i'll get over when when we can
socialize again
perhaps so um yeah he i met
and i was like i want to make a good
impression why not i do
and then uh and then hush got brought up
and then uh jimmy's
boyfriend works with hearing impaired
yes
and then i here i was raving about a
movie at a table with them and then they
they immediately
went to the argument about how it's
actually really offensive and
explained to me in great detail why i
was like i'm glad
i'm i'm glad i'm meeting you guys we're
so sorry i really came prepared for that
oh we gotta we gotta redo it then
someday you'll meet jimmy and jc again
and we'll have a whole different intro
i forget that mike flanagan did ouija
origin of evil
i know i constantly forget he did that
yeah man and pony smasher did annabelle
the second one there's some like then
david f sandberg did annabelle
annabelle uh creation annabelle creation
which and by the way i'm just gonna
throw this out here i think animal comes
home is an underrated movie
i thought that i would pretty [ __ ] i
would watch annabelle comes home during
halloween time i would that is a fun
house horror movie
i don't care what the [ __ ] people say
yeah it's better than the first
annabelle it's better than a lot of the
conjuring movies
um actually no it's better than none in
annabelle
annabelle comes home is is a is a really
really fun movie
um but yeah ouija origin evil gerald's
game
brilliant and dr sleep the movie where
john and i disagreed with the world on
yeah that was an uncomfortable one to do
because we were like
um hush is not if people are saying like
why is hush offensive hush is not
offensive
it it basically if someone the argument
that i've heard a lot of people who uh
work with a hearing impaired is that
a lot of the scary stuff that happens
like ooh because she
can't hear and she's mute that that she
would like no she would be able to
detect this killer who's stalking her
basically is the argument
that kept getting thrown around realism
but dr
sleep uh is a movie that john and i
we're not big fans of
no and everyone else is a big fan of
that movie
is the one it was the one in that lane
that came the closest i still want to
see the director's cut but yeah the
theatrical
is not great especially if you've seen
haunting of hill house because then
you're just sitting here wishing it was
that
yeah which is an interesting
like i saw a good amount of the actual
60s film the haunting just recently
which comes from the same source
material
and that's a fascinating story to watch
get redone over time because there's
like the 1999 movie with liam neeson and
owen wilson
and that's got its own version and then
you know you got the mini series which
is a whole like family drive
made me wonder what the actual book is
about you got
i like jimmy freckles comment in the
chat let me give you some wisdom
it's not offensive if you're not
offended
that's not bad man that's not bad it's
not cold if you're not cold
all right john help me out here what am
i doing all right got it that's it all
right just gotta make sure we have it
we've had this through like hey guys
three labs and we haven't even checked
on stream labs for the at once during
the hour to see if anyone's did anything
all right
oh we got a couple ten three ten three
ten two oh we got a few three ten three
oh man we got a few
we're behind here we're behind but
really quick i want to check in on the
actual uh
chat once uh like no no that's cool you
keep it up keep enough now i don't i
don't want to forget
uh i haven't seen blind manner yet wait
is blind or out it's not
out yet i don't think is it blind matter
come out did it drop like today
did it i haven't been on netflix
live streaming blind manner come out is
it worth watching
like as a reaction or something or just
is it worth watching at all
i haven't heard anything about it no i i
feel like they'd be like pushing this
yeah i feel like it would be a really
big deal if it had just come out
i'm not seeing anything about it i feel
like it's it's about i mean it's
dropping this month
yeah of course yeah but it's good man
yeah me too and i'm excited to see them
build like their own american horror
story troop here
oh gosh let's see here
jeepers creepers don't watch that don't
support that movie yeah
don't support that movie i liked the
first one but that guy
is not a good human being or a victor
salva
we're always behind some convicted
pedophiles somehow we will end by 7
25 today guys i'm gonna we're gonna make
sure it's happening
and we're still gonna give quality
answers hey
uh somebody asked i mean we're on cameo
we we could read you we could read to
you on camera
vlev doran what's up phleb hi guys
can't stay up to watch the stream live
but i wanted to
yeah i thought it said pooping but i
wanted to pop in
i don't have a traditional film to watch
because there's no halloween in my
country
oh that's a bummer we'll start it is
there like some kind of autumn harvest
festival celebrate it man who gives a
[ __ ] yeah go for it
there it doesn't matter now but in terms
of spooky films i like to rewatch
scream series and also casper if that
counts we really covered it and flev
thanks for the support i appreciate you
popping in regardless
appreciate the tip buddy phleb i hope
you're getting some good sleep right now
eric horseman my man eric
uh huh let me punch this in a tad bit
punch it up
that's too much that's what did you do
intelligible i just wanted you to be
able to read one word of the god
eric buddy thank you buddy thanks
darling all right slow your roll buddy
where you got hey guys
first i've done a 15th rewatch of the
haunting of hill house to get ready for
blind manor
even though it's not connected
but good that you're prepared i really
wanted to cement my love for haunting of
hill house
i just wanted to say i will undoubtedly
compare
the seasons with each other as they're
meant to be done another please
uh to you please react on patreon second
watching all my favorite horrors each
week starting with the evil dead
john you have a phone at home i do
time for you to watch all of haunting a
blind manor
by yourself and satisfy her of course i
mean
if i could just do keep it going and not
the highlights then
tuesday in the chat hey welcome erica
she just got here there she is
what's up y'all sup erica how you doing
welcome it wouldn't be spooky how's your
chuck e cheese coming along because
that's a halloween in and of itself
we'll see man i mean do people want us
to watch hunting a blind manor can we
hire someone
to edit that for us i
i just don't know i guess the time i
feel like the mandalorians gonna be the
thing
but that's way at the end of the month
we got one more episode of the boys
because we ideally want to do is i have
at least one tv show recovering on
on youtube once a month oh you know like
throughout the month
basically but with netflix i feel like
we gotta like well we gotta dish that
out right away because all the episodes
are out
yeah it's a bit of a pressure cooker on
that one and if we're committing if
we're committing to like shooting and
editing that ourselves
we're never going to be able to cover
anything that comes out there's any
movie news or other big channels we're
like that's gonna have to wait man oh
yeah yeah
work on this [ __ ] show i mean unless
unless we did one where it's no
highlights and just stream along
but i don't but eric um i definitely
want to watch it though we do want to
watch it definitely definitely
it's not off the table i'll tell you
that it's not off the table
we definitely we it's it's definitely a
heavy consideration at the moment yeah i
i sincerely mean that buddy i really do
i'm not just saying that
sincerely mean it just i also feel like
when looking at the trailers
for haunting a blind manner because you
gotta consider that that's gonna
take us many many many many hours to
edit so we want to make sure it's
something that draws an audience as
people watching
is uh when i look at the trailers are
hunting a blind manor
i i i feel like not many people are
really watching the trailer
comparatively you know it's usually a
good way to gauge whether or not people
watch your tv reaction
is by how well the trailer's doing i
could tell john's not listening
he's clearly just reading the chat about
how the trailer is doing
oh that's oh i know i know the trick you
hear the last thing i say
and then you repeat that back because
that's what your little subconscious are
talking about hill house no i'm talking
about blind manor
well you know but no john your universe
the time
for greg to end his reign of being nice
to john
ends right now hashtag john's fault for
ruining the rain
uh it's okay it's okay we made it a good
hour and a half
oh yeah man oh james mama's geeky and
the chat is talking about doing that you
know like having to edit the 10 plus
it like umbrella academy was a big
learning lesson
we edit that on patreon keep them a tad
bit longer
um but on youtube you got to be
exceptionally strict
and uh man yeah like editing for
umbrella accounting like
this takes like six to eight our friend
jason dolan just edited
for uh uh cassie reacts with the joker
movie reaction but he said it took about
24 hours to edit
those things take a long time so it's
like if we're gonna commit the time to
covering one of these
you can't blame especially if you don't
have someone to hire for at that
particular time
you're going to want to make sure a that
this is something that could be
monetized for the amount of time it's
going to take
or outsource an editor for and also
if you're gonna edit it yourself you're
gonna wanna make sure that in some way
you know you're drawing in an audience
with this yeah because yeah
taking out umbrella academy was like oh
that
i i love the show and i actually love
the experience of editing it because i
love
i feel proud of the way those videos
turned out um
at the same time though oh yeah those
are like six to eight hours each
just just the edit uh you know so
not to mention the other the excess you
know like thumbing and you know
stuff and then of course like you know
filming the reaction is one thing but
also you know you want to make sure
we're reviewing it and all that yeah
anyway but yeah
uh well it's not off the table though
buddy they'll all be up in the same day
oh yeah bradley who doesn't want to add
it well that's it it's not off the table
well it's not off the table it's not off
the table real quick
awesomeness mike have seen the cobra kai
season 3
45 second teaser and uh very excited for
it
nonetheless i mean we want to we're
waiting for the actual official trailer
of cobra kai
season 3 to come out that was an
announcement trailer with some brief
images
and blah blah blah and i know people
have been asking for it but personally
we want something but when a trailer
comes out we feel like we have something
we could really talk about
really leaves an impact especially
because
netflix is difficult to work around
so that's why their content
um but yeah mama's geeky i'm really
happy to see mama's geeky in the chat
right now yeah
i really am man it's great to have her
here hey
so uh eric was here and yes love for
jane levy mark leitch i feel you
wait what did my hero academia season
five trailers out
is it now that's we need to try to get a
copyright strike over
yeah um okay
oh i'm really happy to see mama's geek
here yeah erica eric was here
back out again session nine yeah it's
one of the most underrated horror movie
is is the is one of yes so [ __ ]
creepy
definitely recommended haven't seen
session now what is that uh it is a
movie
i can't remember if it has a full-on
found footage bent or not but it's
basically about this crew who goes into
like an abandoned mental asylum to do
some rehab work or something sort of
you know i can't remember exactly why
they go in now but yeah it's one of
those movies that takes place in like an
abandoned asylum and there's something
you know
freaky going on and it's got david
caruso in one of them
yeah i slipped on my own armrest you
guys see that
whoa but it's got david caruso in a role
that he's actually just acting in
and not like doing his like csi miami
like scene
gnawing so it's like an actual movie
that features him it's good
well thank you for that thank you you
really sold me it was it was not a good
pitch you really
you really saw me that movie that that
session
something very exciting well then
because i was thinking about like oh man
i gotta think back now because i've only
seen it the one time
but uh i really like the way you said
you're like yes
well no because i wait but you know i
don't even know what it is because
session nine has held on for so long i i
feel like that's the thing i can't
remember
is it i can't remember exactly when it
came out i feel like it's at least a
decade old though and and that's a movie
that you know never i don't think got
any big release or anything but that has
just held on
in the sort of horror just like
underrated movies been so yeah
session nine like often gets brought up
and and for good reason i think
yeah man so it's worth checking out g
it's a supernatural uh psychological
horror
always watch pumpkin head every
halloween he says
total classic it is what's pumpkin head
john pumpkin head is
uh like a fantasy horror movie
about this like uh this this father who
i believe like doing it
who loses a child and he summons this
monster and it goes awry from there and
the monster is called pumpkinhead and
the funny thing about that movie was i'd
heard about it for so long i'd seen the
design of the creature i was like
oh this has got to be kind of like a
silly movie and while it is
kooky in ways i think that's an
underrated
like it's easy to look at pumpkin head
and be like oh you know
schlocky fun horror movie but you know
lance henriksen really puts us all into
that flick and the effects are great and
it's actually pretty chilling
i have not seen head yeah yeah
but sort of a cautionary tale there's a
couple of these movies i won't watch
pumpkin head i want to watch rubber
and i will say in the chat i'm seeing a
lot of people saying
tucker and dale versus evil typed it in
[Music]
[Music]
ah okay i'd be a water bender rosie
for what which one would you be a water
bender airbender firebender earthbender
oh i'd definitely be a dirt bender dirt
bag my name dirt bender
my name dirt bender i'm dirt bender i'm
the dirt uh let's see here nancy aka
alex uh hi nancy or alex
hi nancy alex nice to meet you alex have
we met
before my sweet net nan for all i thank
you for being here for all i love
horror movies the three i usually watch
around halloween are arsenic and old
lace great movie
my girlfriend introduced me to that
movie great movie that's a
that to me is an old-time hollywood film
that i think even if you're someone
who's like i'm not a really
big fan of those kind of movies or
classics i think you could actu if you
give it like 10 minutes
i think you would actually really enjoy
it it's really funny
signs and thank you for citing signs
okay i'm sorry like the last 15 minutes
i like it and sleepy hollow which is one
of the most
perfect movies to watch around halloween
that is a definite goat
often marathon the weekend of with
friends so she's watching the show
friends in between she's watching movies
like this
sleepy hollow is an absolute go-to movie
for halloween yeah i don't know why
this is the first time it's been brought
up in this stream
but yes yeah absolutely 100 such aura
and mood to that story and
it's perfect because it gets help from
being like already the short story is a
halloween thing so then the movie
version takes
that much further it's one of the few
movies that like really drastically
reimagines a classic story in a way that
just
totally worked for me yeah didn't feel
like they were trying too hard
ethan holgate thanks for being here
ethan ehg
hi guys just out of curiosity i know
it's not a halloween movie
question but have you ever seen edgar
wright's first movie called a fist full
of fingers
you i haven't john you're supposed to be
the edgar wright guy i'm failing i don't
like him
clearly i clearly have outed myself as a
phony
low-budget western movie he made in the
90s also usually around halloween time i
watch
any horror movie which which i feel like
if you're not like a horror buff
like halloween is horror movies time you
know yeah
but uh i don't i just don't feel like
it's all subjective but
i i don't almost feel like i feel like
there's certain kinds of horror movies i
just wouldn't call a horror movie
i'd care to put on halloween well this
that's to me
i feel like the the amount of halloween
movies to horror movies is like a way
smaller
niche you know because there's so much
stuff that yeah is based on
horrific macabre stuff but like a lot of
slasher movies don't say halloween to me
yeah they murdered
me the hills have eyes part
two
i wouldn't even watch like last house on
the left i'm obviously naming very
specific kinds of movies
but yeah i wouldn't watch that um but
you know
but i could write shawn of the dead i
would watch for sure yeah we're talking
about edgar wright i watched sean of the
dead
well actually his next movie is
apparently like a straight
horror movie so i'm excited to hear that
uh see that homophobic [ __ ] see
what i did there look at there
straight people alan smithy hey
i love your films what are great great
great name
jealousy not real jealous so yeah who's
alan smithy
it's the it's the pseudonym directors
take when they don't want their name on
a movie like what david lynch did
yeah dude we've already tried doing i
think for like the tv releases or
extended edition he did that
yes um but thanks alan smithy for being
here
hey rejects thank you
it's not it's not nice being called
rejects just want to point that out hey
rejects
yeah what a dick thing to say i got pink
on my
face everyone who addressed we never
embraced the brand
go [ __ ] yourself man i don't i don't
just come up to you and say things like
that
uh on cameo i think ricky's looking only
for you on cameo
okay i mean it'll go to us either way
uh but uh we'll all be there find me
find us we still have a cameo i don't
know if we shut it down
we're it's it's still there real rejects
still there real rejects i don't forget
hey rejects
we'll we'll have to find it later and
we'll we'll put it in the ping comment
say ricky vidcon here's our cameo
hey rejects i love the movie the mist
even though i
hate the special ending that frank
derebond added
the rest of the movie is pretty gnarly
um
soups gnar bro and the creatures are
fantastic
especially love the scene with the acid
spiders
have you guys seen it yes indeed i've
seen it in color in black and white
we will call you reject nation but don't
call us rejects
[Laughter]
we're hypocrites that's right ah that's
the cornerstone of this operation
i love the uh john loves the mist more
than i do i like the ending
it basically is the difference i hate
the ending i i really do i can't get
past some logic
that just bothers me a lot there uh
i know john i don't wanna argue with
john about it all right i
don't like the ending john likes the
ending and
if i like the ending i might love that
movie more
but for the most part i really
appreciate that movie i think it's
really well executed
and i think it's a great thriller and uh
it's a wonderful performances thomas
jane
probably the most underrated actor
today i'd say i say the most underrated
male
white actor if there's a category for
underrated
that's an important category to fill he
is though man
i mean the problem is like he's good in
everything
every movie he's good in he was one of
the best parts of the predator
he's the which i didn't care for people
were
good he was good in uh freaking like the
punisher movie people don't like but
people love him
as the punisher he got his own shorts
he's a great
man so i would say thomas jane is the
most
underrated white male actor
working today the problem is there's so
many white actors working that if you
really stop to take a list of all the
underrated white actors it would
probably still outnumber
all the best actors of every other race
damn mama's geeky agrees with you that's
the truth
it's got 50 000 subscribers so i'm wrong
there you go that's how i measure your
opinion guys
i feel very vindicated in this moment to
know that i was correct all this time
this person's more popular so they must
be right
that's how you decide what i believe
there's a a
famous quote this is your attraction
popular
is correct this is the part of the
stream when
it's always right around this when i
start to feel loopy
then i check how long we've been live
and i go
yep that's that part of this don't fly
off the handle eric
i'm way wrong on the missed ending here
proven what message did you retract
bring it back what did you do eric
don't don't don't don't bring me down
don't bring me down
yeah electric light organizations don't
bring me down
uh i i have no idea what our cameo is
all right i personally don't have the
app all right i'll tell you i'll take
care of resetting
i got the app i said 7 20 is when this
would end
all right michael as well hey andrew
bowers i
really appreciate you saying that um
it's great having you here
means a lot carissa ludden movie talk
love seeing you here too that do you
have like a channel
is that is it like an actual channel
that's a great name lovecraft country
i'm i'm planning on binging that once
it's done so i could have it spoiled for
me at the last minute that's the way to
do it
my favorite experience is when i'm
binging something and then it gets
ruined for me
right before i reach the last episode
that's always
always the way i wish to experience it
it takes the pressure off you know that
finale
oh man we got so many super chats that
we have
just missed we gotta we gotta blow
through them
yeah blow through them we gotta blow
through them we gotta do it
how other youtubers blow through them
are you taking jabs at
i don't know hard shots i don't watch
too many other live streams to
[Music]
just say like you know they just shout
their name
and quickly move past it alrighty so we
got this is our chance people are always
like
start a podcast and to me the live
streams are our podcast
yeah basically and basically our podcast
on patreon is just another version of
the live stream
yeah there's a little more editing
involved but not much
so yeah man yeah that's what i would say
pretty soon everything will be just be
done in this form who said greg is cool
too
greg is amazing greg is cool too greg is
cool too hate being compared to john
all right never lose your nerd thank you
never lose your nerd you know we love
the [ __ ] out of your name
yes yeah [ __ ] out of the name [ __ ] you
out of the conjuring wanted to yeah
pickle rick whoo the country went to
legit scary as [ __ ]
movies for any occasion not any
specifically for halloween
but love those two love you guys as
always never lose your nerd
we love you and conjuring one and two
are great films who do you get to do
conjuring three again
the guy who did la yorona michael
chavez i think uh i apparently i haven't
even
seen la llorona and i'm like wow i
haven't even seen la
rona and i'm super bummed that was the
movie where i was like oh please do like
the justice but no from what i know man
i mean i liked the billy eilish music
video he directed
yeah absolutely dude you know that's a
that's a good but yeah that's apparently
no that's a bummer dude he ha
james one fire the guy who directed la
yorona
and come back for conjuring three you
have time to make your schedule work
it's only gonna take you like two years
to make aquaman too
and the trench come on dude what the
[ __ ]
michael b you're still in this chat
michael b usually leaves
good to see you here michael b mama's
geeky one day we will we'll we'll figure
it out man
where are you from mama's geeky i i
don't know where you're resided
kim wexler favorite true blood character
lafayette
you know why i think the live streams
are our podcast more than anything else
is because i the first kind of version
of podcasting i ever
really got addicted to was it was a
radio show
that used to exist called love line
which was you take
calls from listeners and then it was all
about that
yeah and it was about relationships sex
it's like not at all about movies and
stuff it was about like relationships
and sex
and mental conditions all these things
right mental health conditions
and um because of that i think that's
why my
most comfortable form of podcasting is
in the form of live streaming
yeah you know so it's not about like
breezing through even though
it's about enjoying the you know i i
would like to go about 7
20 to 7 30. based off of some other
things i got to handle tonight
yeah but i will say that uh yeah i i
i personally like this is my favorite
version of doing uh
any kind of podcast every [ __ ]
goddamn question what's the question
we're back at it again some of my fave
halloween films with humor
are tucker and dave i will say i gotta
point out really quick
arctic tuesday i will say even though
i've grown i grew up
on uh love line in recent years with dr
drew i've slowly been like i'm not sure
i'm gonna listen to this guy anymore
but i love love line i will meet you
there man
i don't know anything about this other
than i just watched that first episode
of midnight radio who and that was
delightful but
uh marika leach what are we at some of
my favorite halloween films with humor
are tucker and dale versus evil yes we
specifically siphoned that
yes sean of the dead yes sir and
zombieland which has my future redhead
wife
emma stone in it what if you
you got emma stone let's let's i want to
paint a scenario i would love to talk
about the movies but i feel like we've
talked about all them except for
zombieland which is great love the
writers
we interview them watch that video paul
wernick
what if this scenario of her being your
future wife
is she goes through a terrible drug
addiction
and she becomes an alcoholic and then
emma stone's career goes way downhill
and she's lost a couple of teeth and
she's just not working anymore and then
you meet her at a bar
would you still want her to be your
future wife absolutely
that's the time i'm just saying
[Laughter]
but no those are all great picks and uh
all those movies i really do love
fantastic picks fantastic pic the best
picks
the best pics ever the best movies the
best halloween
i didn't listen to uh uh uh love line
when it was
adam carolla though you were psycho mike
i was a psycho mic error guy yeah
oh it's her humbled up my system
preferences guys
let's just open it we're doing a tech
live stream let's open up the
administrative let's
open up what's our storage unit here
what are all our passwords
uh let's see here uh
travis austin travis austin thank you
dude that's a really big contribution
man thank you my golly it's been a i
feel like we've seen your name around
here before
yeah but it's definitely been a while
that's a sexy profile
thank you travis that's a really big
this really generous contribution man
love the live streams halloween is like
every day for me i'm constantly going
out stealing
murdering people getting candy from
children being
spooked by ghosts all the time knocking
on people's door
in costumes asking for free food smell
my feet
can i have food you know no one thinks
i'm funnier
than me that's good and i think
everyone thinks that you know why
because everyone makes
jokes that they think are funny that
occasionally no one else is laughing at
so if i can admit that i
no one finds me fired
in some way we all think that about
ourselves yeah
because you got to find yourself funny
in order to throw those jokes out bro
um yo candy man's a great movie
sylvester i appreciate
it it is a terrific love the live
streams halloween's like every day for
me i
frequently rewatch i could read it from
here so i'm looking more you guys
i frequently rewatch knight of the
demons trilogy
wow unique picks that's one i got whoa
this guy has deep cuts motel hell
rabbit return of the living dead prom
night
to hello mary lou
keep it spooky and sexy guys those are
some great pics man
i'm so glad you you name checked hello i
haven't seen any of those movies
besides return of the living dead turn a
living dead
holy [ __ ] is great motel hell is pretty
wild do you mean rabbit like the one
with guy pierce that's like the
australian movie from like a deck like
guy pierce second most underrated white
male actor he is an underrated white
male actor guys
jane that should be her next livestream
yes these guys are just getting the
short end of the stick
these white guys need more work what the
[ __ ]
these guys aren't showing love and i'm
sorry that
jai courtney's done some horrible
blockbuster films but he's good in some
other ones
he's good in jack these are some great
deep cuts man
i appreciate these picks travis austin i
really do
i do too um thank you so much yeah bud
peter pacheco petey's back i appreciate
all the compliments and
after after self-complimenting myself
okay all these compliments in the chat
hey that's how you know that you're on
the right track doing a good job here
oh no i'm thinking of ravenous there you
go thank you mark
is is rabbit the one that just came out
then or am i thinking of a different
movie clear it up in the in the thing
rocky horror picture show i i am waiting
for
theaters to open back up so we can go
watch that one
i've never seen it never seen rocky or a
picture show oh you'll get to be a
virgin
always had the excuse of i want to watch
it in theaters with a crowd that goes
crazy
that's the way uh boo a medea halloween
one and two
damn hell yeah man i like someone
listening some tyler perry [ __ ]
goosebumps one and two hey he likes the
second one goosebumps show is a good one
to watch too
dude ryan gosling you want to see him in
an early role go watch goosebumps
batman forever third act takes place on
halloween and scooby doo
boogie oh god forever took place oh
that's right the trick-or-treaters and
two-face and riddler show up that's
right i forgot about that halloween
classic right there
oh man yeah just mad respect to
listening
tyler perry movies no one ever lists
tyler perry movies
he's the most successful he's the most
underrated white actor i think he's the
most underrated white actor working
today
he takes the top spot you know what i
will say i think tyler perry is an
underrated actor because
every once in a while i'm leaving yeah i
have to go guys i have to work tomorrow
[ __ ]
love you list all the underrated white
actors please thank you
yes no tyler perry like occasionally
shows up in movies for like supporting
roles where he all
like becomes the best part yeah man
somehow and i don't know what like why
he doesn't do more of that
ah i guess you don't need to when you
feel yeah the only reason i haven't seen
it is because i'm waiting for theaters
to open up because i want to go with the
crowd experience that cult experience
where everyone's talking the whole time
and doing their thing and singing along
i don't know what the hell
is th i don't i don't get the community
but i feel like in order to understand
rocket for a picture show i feel like
you really gotta experience the
community in some way
uh to really grasp grasp that you know
yeah
i know so even though i'd be like guys
i'm trying to hear the movie
his experience i don't understand uh
yeah sylvester fryson who's been talking
throughout this whole livestream
finally got to your super chat buddy you
know how we take forever thank you
sylvester
this is how we do you guys mr stream i'm
glad you guys are still
rocking the channel dude dude sly
for you for any time you're the main
reason we have this channel
for you sly you you're like this guy
needs some entertainment
if we lost all consecutive viewers right
now and it was just you sly
we'd stay live for you
yeah in fact if you're not the last
person in this stream
i'm gonna be real mad i will admit
though if if that happened we'd be we'd
be
very depressed we we would just be
really sad and we'd be asking you for
advice the whole time going
sly why we lose all the viewers
help
do we read the submissions too slowly
what's going on
um but thank you sly i appreciate that
buddy uh
anissa anisa i think you all know it's
monster squad of course you would say
monster squad she brings up
she brings up monster squad the way mike
brings up star trek on red letter media
every week
i would say nissa brings up monster
squad no matter what
wolfman's got nards hey tm don't test it
tm
don't test it don't test the tm don't
test the tm
test sylvester says i would still be
here oh thanks buddy
uh eric horseman buddy another
underrated horror movie is
effing amazing splinter with the hot as
hell
jill wagner great call i think i've
i've seen footage of this i've never
seen the actual movie this is like in it
but it's an
eric horseman film you can pick up on
eric horstmann's taste buds by coming
every so by watching every live stream
and seeing what he puts down
yeah it's an eric horseman joint for
sure i really want a curated
just list of eric horseman like approved
films
because like if you were the curator of
some kind of film festival i think it
would be wild
splinter though i i've only seen little
parts on tv
first like an indie horror movie i don't
i don't know why what eric horseman
listed here
is reminding me of this underrated
horror movie but i got an underrated
horror movie i like to throw you guys
away
that also stars a woman it is
called what is it called
mimic guillermo del toro's mimic cool
did anyone else see
mimic when they were younger or recently
for the first time because mimick
creeped me the [ __ ] out have you seen
mimik i haven't
well i'm gonna have to end this
conversation then isn't it johnny
mix going on my list oh yeah that's a
great one
i think it's been a long time i don't
remember the film might not be good
anymore
hey you know i hope it holds up eric
needs to send a little
you know what i i kind of might want to
cover blind manor
only for eric i mean what if we just
found a way to
there's got to be a way to make a tear
well i was sitting here thinking about
it i was like if we could just pipe the
footage in like through stream labs or
something and just do it all in one
big recording like oh man we should do a
12
hour netflix yeah that's a sure way to
get that stream blocked
not for well maybe just put up the time
code
very hard to keep the time code going
yes yes yes
but we could make it work we could
figure something out someday michael b
here he is buddy we finally made it to
your super chat um
uh thank you omni media follow this guy
he kills it gerardo species
great call [ __ ] great call yeah
um michael b is saying
what trope will five what
scream five oh what trope well five pl
how did you know
uh well i was like he can't be talking
about pressure
he's not talking presidents so it has to
be screamed
what trope will screen five play with
reboot quills somehow make everything
after one not canon like halloween and
terminator what's the plan
ah i have no idea what screen five will
play with but i
i was gonna initially my mind initially
went to um specifically reboots
um but they did what was screen 4
playing on
reboots in in a lot of ways soft reboots
soft reboots they did a lot of
commentary on torture porn for whatever
reason but yeah like
the the reboot i feel like was the whole
idea because it's going to be like
bigger and more blood and crazier and
stuff there's got to be something there
that i feel like there's something to
tap into
that i don't i don't know exactly what
they would tap into but horror
has become a lot more popular and more
respected of a genre too
so i think there's something for
especially if after seeing what those
guys did with ready or not
i don't know screen five will tap into
indie horror
that's what they'll do it'll go into
independent horror films yeah these days
a horror movie can't
to like really get crazy into the last
five minutes yeah everybody knows that
maybe they they can tap into kind of the
idea
of of canceling all the sequels that
came after it
i think that was a version where they
could do that i think it would be
it could potentially be a very wacky
thing to do but i
also feel like there would be something
to do with that because it is the new
thing
and especially they could cap into like
now nev campbell's coming back
and of the commentary of how oh man
[ __ ] like
oh yeah we can't do this without
bringing back the original even though
the person storylines done
i feel they'll have a very self-aware
commentary in screen five
or maybe they'll do some kind of
commentary about how she has to come
back as like the grizzled
badass warrior woman or something like a
sarah connor
um but yeah that might be it michael b
thank you for the question my
buddy follow omni media i mean it i
watch his videos on my own time
from time to time they're just gonna
make fun of binging
they're just gonna make fun of binge
watching in this movie uh
mark leach scream is my favorite also
also with the thing but
martyrs eden lake pony oh
uh ponte pool piney pump pony tea party
pony tea poo
pony tea poo eating eaten like more and
green room
eden lake is one thing and then i think
ponte pulls another
and then yeah mid-summer and green room
and uh
dude pawnee pool is cool that's a cool
ass movie and and it's
strange but very underrated go check it
out stephen mccaddy is amazing in it
i have not seen that i've seen green
room
which i i would make an argument is it
really a horror and i
i'd say yeah yeah it's just
right there to be to be on actual horror
film cause it has
those elements of home invasion capture
and torture you know it's like
even though they don't live at the venue
it still feels like kind of a home
invasion we gotta like elude
people in a domestic like place
space my favorite kind of questions in
the live stream are when people like
pandemic jones ask like customer service
questions
is the thing on any streaming service
oh let me look that up for you sir this
should be the only questions
it's not streaming for free but it's
available for rental for 299.
that was a reputable deal funny if those
are all like the super chat questions
that we get
guys are they making cobra kai season 4
um
yes xavier welcome to the stream buddy
welcome just in time
just in time we're kicking it off uh but
yeah thanks for the picks there mark
leach
john you're you have a bottle that is
blocking the name the juicy
bandit i just wanted to be able to say
it myself
what's up juice i love your pensive
profile
juicy bandit what a great name the juicy
bandit
hey guys oh big fan of the bottom juicy
bandit
that's when he unsubscribes no i'm not
i'm neither how dare you i'm a middle
yeah hey guys big fan of the channel
especially the scary vid reaction
also loving this season of the boys
thank you i'm
very glad you're enjoying all those
things i appreciate you enjoying the
scary vid reactions i feel like though
people have been losing interest in the
scary vid reactions
it makes my heart sad to see that i know
it's a bummer yeah
you know how i can tell by the view
count
it's the damn thing i'm not sure what it
is well it's kind of an indicator that
people have kind of been losing interest
in it hey man if you love them
spread the petition we used to only do
them around halloween time maybe that's
the thing and this was the first
year where we were kind of doing it
every month yeah and i feel like there's
somewhere down the middle
it just it was like ah no so maybe we
should just reserve them all for
halloween again
but i was just noticing that in february
that there were people who kept watching
them
even though i was like damn these are
kind of old videos
remember get out did really well in
february so it's february sorry about
february
october yeah that are the two spooky
months
uh let's see here but juicy bandit
appreciate the the contribution and i
hope you enjoy our reaction the boys
it's up tomorrow episode seven tomorrow
because
we love spoiler alert we loved it we
really liked
that all three of us didn't all three of
us love that episode yes
all right on the raj what's up buddy
what's up buddy my favorite stop the
scary vids
ever there's a point we almost wanted to
stop reviews we're facial hair bros
another ponytail yeah i got several
do you want a scrunchie or do you want a
regular uh
scrunchie okay cool there you go let's
all just take a moment to be silent here
on the stream
oh oh yeah
we should like really [ __ ] with the
audience one day there should be a
moment where we should just be like
really in the middle of a conversation
then freeze frame
and people think we just glitched it
yeah see how long we can keep that up
for and then have people in the chat
being like no i saw the move
they're not moving you know it's just
it's it's just the extra frames can you
answer
nuclear's question thermonuclear where
he keeps asking what we think of
chernobyl diaries and i haven't seen
chernobyl
oh thermonuclear i liked the concept
a lot i've only seen like the first
15 minutes though so i couldn't really
give you an opinion
uh i was bummed to see it do so poorly
it seems like one of those concepts that
is
perhaps misguided and insensitive but
also
radioactive monsters are a genre i like
so
i'd be curious to watch it at some point
the same way i watched apollo 18.
i would be a curious like that movie is
not great but you know if you want an
old
60s space found footage movie
it's decent for that so i'll i'll let
you know if i ever check out your noble
diaries
i thought you've seen it i'm sorry
i wanted to at the time and then i
started watching it on
on netflix can i ask can do you have a
ponytail
yes i said i said no did i ask can i do
you have a ponytail john
and you went yeah do you want a
scrunchie or a regular
so you knew what i was asking you yeah
yeah i don't know i mean it's because i
saw pj quote me
do you have a ponytail i was like
what did i say that well yeah cause i
don't know it's one of those
it's ponytail and hair tie or elastic
band or scrunchie or whatever you know
they're synonymous i know what you're
looking for
yeah i i i would like to see all the
scrunchies
that's right guys subscribe to mama's
geeky today
mm-hmm and tomorrow and every day and
every day keep resubscribing confuse the
hell out of her
algorithm you keep losing keep getting
subscribers right now every day
it's weird we're getting tons and tons
of engagement
but never grow
so let's see here uh i think they were
talking about the chernobyl series by
the way
um oh you mean just cherno chernobyl is
amazing and i mean that is a nightmarish
show in and of itself so i mean go watch
that for sure that's a great mini series
six episodes
niraj krishnan
my favorite was an indian movie made in
the 70s which translates to house number
13.
great insight john you're the horror
buff tell them about
niraja's indian horror movie house
number 13 predict the plot
go for it watch john's improv skills
okay watch john's improv
get it this cannot tout this enough his
improv skills
are amazing john go for it you're gonna
be ready to compliment john on his
improv skills what is house number
thirteen about
pitch it to us elevator house number one
is one of the terrific horror thriller
about a real estate
developer who's just about to sell his
last house
before retirement and it's it's which
house
it's the twi it's the 13th house but
guess what that's an unlucky number and
people don't want to buy it so he has to
get
desperate in order to sell it and that
leads him down this
pathway of depravity as he tortures
people until they agree live in the
house
and also there's a love story backed by
music
not very heavily remated to the main
plot
now what do you guys think because that
is
this might surprise you john just made
all that
that's what improv is which is not short
that is not the actual plot nope i've
never heard of this but i would like
a 70s kd
ah a 70s like indian movie though would
be especially interesting to me because
yeah i've seen like a
a handful of indian movies in my life i
don't think everyone that old
so john's favorite horror franchise is
the human center be
andrew um mark leach i do like that
i loved scary film thank you again mark
leitch
i loved scary films as a kid like
witches tremors and
jaws aliens etc i loved coraline even
though i was older what film freaked
you out as a kid you know what really
freaked me out which is ironic
because i didn't actually see the movie
till way after i saw this
uh i saw an entertainment weekly
magazine
that had the one of the photos of the
the exorcist girl
and for some reason it just
haunted me for like two years and i
avoided the movie because it scared me
that much
and then eventually i watched the movie
and i was like that's not too bad
but when i was kid that image just
freaked out
every time like i saw like a dark window
i'd imagine her face being there it
really [ __ ] with me
mm-hmm you mean like little reagan with
the like icky slashes and stuff for like
the possession
of your face no just just your face just
a regular human face not uh much later
in life the beginning of the
photo linda blair i'm like oh she didn't
age well
actually just quite gracious
she looks like linda blake but uh yeah
that was uh
yeah i always see what freaked you as a
kid john we got jeffrey dean morgan as
the most underrated white actor
and white actors being unacknowledged
freaks me out
uh no what freaked me out as a kid uh
it's not a movie but the
i have the beholder episode of the
twilight zone with the people with the
pig faces
really really freaked me out that's one
of my earliest memories of like being
too much and then uh when the mummy came
out funny enough
the scarab beetles that would go under
your skin
it took me a long time to like be able
to watch that actually because yeah like
those scenes and especially when the one
dude loses his eyes and tongue like
that actually uh got me pretty freaked
as a kid so
ah the shining too definitely shining
especially scared me a lot
watch it as a little kid the woman in
the bathtub was the thing that haunted
me
that was a little bit of a little bit
yeah
and actually if my most honest answer
was anaconda
there's a reason why i'm afraid a snake
will be in my toilet one day and
shoot up my butthole that's where they
go that's where they go it's
real before you know it's their fear of
mine is they're so greasy
are you being sarcastic that was an
actual fear i had for many years
um i don't know what i'm doing the craft
and jennifer's body both
dope christina is pulling a translucent
super chat on us i get it because
there's nothing here to talk about
why isn't there anything here for us to
rip on
christina we're giving her something to
talk about because if you remember
translucent's
true superpower is reading body language
but appreciate the super chat though
christina appreciate you showing us some
love
hopefully your name pops back up here in
a regular chat i'm not worried about
taking too much time on this one so
thank you for that
thanks for being here kate hey brendan v
what's up dude
brendan v ready pickle rick
how you doing brandon i hope your i hope
time has been uh
helped you in healing so
damn butthole snakes trying
trying to watch a horror movie each day
in october yesterday
was the wretched tonight is the witches
tomorrow the craft love you guys i don't
think i know the wretched
if you guys haven't seen our witch's
reaction please check it out
um we haven't seen the wretched and the
craft
i think i've seen i know that
skeet ulrich and nev campbell are in it
which is cool
i know it deals with being kind of
bullied and then they find witchcraft
and then they start
kind of bullying back mm-hmm you know
the perils of power there's good there's
good response to a super chat isn't it
isn't it like the best kind of best kind
of response i think i've seen this movie
it's about this right let me just
explain my vague knowledge of the plot
to you
it's good interaction isn't it yeah
that's how you engage a crowd
you are aware of the craft i'll give you
that
that's a good movie though it's worth uh
i think it's worth looking back at
especially for like 90s movies that hold
up pickle rick thank you mama's geeky
yes
some way this live stream is awesome
mama's geeky's cheers
this live stream is sponsored by mama's
geek but brandon v thank you so much for
that dude
it really means a lot eric horseman you
don't need a drink buddy what you
need is jesus meditate with some christ
in your soul yeah i was like
it's gonna end uh oh ratchet is okay
i've been
i've been so hesitant to watch ratchet
for some reason i i
can't find myself to just start it yeah
why do i feel like i'm going to like
this at first and hate this later
because it's a murphy joint and that's
how it goes a lot
it really strikes me as that oh man
hey okay we are the weirdos 2021 i'm
going to see spiral that's what we're
going to watch
yeah just that but but thank you brendon
v i hope you're doing well buddy i
really do
j mayor former no i'm thinking of
who's the guy in j who's the other
comedian
jay with more more more that's why
that's what i was thinking about
where has that guy been i don't know but
j moore thanks for being here
using the last year residuals to
contribute to our super chats
thanks for small soldiers man seriously
what movies do you plan to watch this
month
i'm watching final destination a nine
round announcer both 1990 and
jeepers creepers well jeepers creepers i
would uh
kind of do a little bit of uh research
on that director there's a reason i will
not watch that movie
i'm rarely that guy too yeah i usually
can i'm pretty good usually it's
separate the whole artist that's the
author
rosemary's baby in spite of knowing
about roman polanski which i feel weird
about
but for jeepers creepers i can't find
myself to do it
yeah like for me jeepers creepers is
such
that like the first jay moore back in
the chat
dude i'm so glad you're a fan because
let me tell you small soldiers
no um jeepers creepers like i it's one
of those things
where i guess because the first movie is
in my mind
and this all happened before we knew and
everything it's like if you own a copy
and you want to watch it that's cool
but yeah just like don't rent it don't
don't like yeah because
because victor salva is not a good guy
he's a convicted
uh offender of the sexual variety
and uh final destination same thing for
that director
nightmare on elm street nope he uh he's
who an insult to man in peace right now
so wes craven and we'll leave samuel
bayer alone for now
first 2017's version which which i
noticed he
had i'm glad that you're going to watch
them both the final destination
i do like final destination and i'll
show you those are great halloween
movies final destination is a series i
have yet to crack
you haven't seen any of it any of them
you are not a real horrible i am a bad
horror
not a real horse i don't like horror
guys you're not a real horrible clearly
i'm not a guy
who likes horror what movies do we plan
to watch this month well i feel like
we've gone over
all that throughout this live stream so
that's why
we uh it's a rift on yours do i have any
that i forget to mention
over here i mean like nosferatu house on
haunted hill
hackson there you go do yourself a favor
if you want to watch a crazy silent
movie from before they had the code to
keep everything appropriate
watch this dutch movie called hackson
it's like a whole
crazy uh it's like a history of
witchcraft but also a realization of
those stories and
yes for the time it was released it it
will kind of blow your mind a little bit
it's a great halloween flick i'm also
gonna watch borat too
dress up in that uh covid masked bikini
of his
yeah by the way i was joking about the
final destination guy i don't know
anything about i don't even know who
directed that so
watch the first jeepers creepers if you
want to as a movie
without the context i like it but yeah
victor salvages don't support him yeah
you can avoid it because
i have good people i haven't seen uh
i don't know anything about the final
destination kdm how do we spell what
whoa why do we suck oh man he says we
suck now
oh sucking's geeky that's too bad
the pandemic jones ma all right pandemic
jones i think
murder documentaries are scary to watch
yeah mr murder documentary
i watched a lot of ted bundy and jeffrey
dahmer
oh you're the first person to mention
this i've been i've been considering
starting this up
this is what we'll react to murder
documentaries they would make good
reactions though
netflix came out with a new doc called
american murder the family next door
that is great uh yeah we saw the trail
we were watching like hunter hunter and
then that ended and then yeah
trailer came up automatically clicks
trailer it automatically plays
and it does look very intriguing i do
want to watch that thanks for
recommending that but yeah murder
documentaries
uh the ones i was obsessed with were for
richard clincy the iceman
um honestly that that that epstein one
was kind of hard to get through so
we haven't continued oh have you haven't
continued tried it oh it was a little
bit hard to get them i just
i just don't feel i feel weird that
seems like it would make me
honestly like i i'm i admire and i'm
fascinated by
the love and and popularity of true
crime and i do think it's fascinating
but truth be told like as a horror movie
fan who could watch horror movies
yeah all year long that's the stuff i
really have to pace myself with because
that's the stuff that really gets under
my skin
and makes me start to just yeah like you
look outside and you're just like oh
anyone could be
you know a terrible terrible murderer
this [ __ ] has freaked me out a lot man
human cruelty scares me the most it
really makes you know like
like uh when netflix first came out
there was this documentary series they
had
this is like before and before netflix
became like this
giant streaming service that influenced
before there's even a thing called
streaming service
the thing that like really influenced
all this
um the first thing we watched was teeth
that's right it's starbucks the first
thing we watched was teeth out of
starbucks john and i got a shared
account because we were like how does
this work
what is this no one's using this oh
let's each pay seven
bucks took forever to load a damn movie
on netflix and it was
brand new and so we spent that time just
hopping around to the gore bits in that
movie can you believe that there's gonna
be there's an arrow where people will
grow up with netflix being an
established thing and we were around for
when
netflix streaming started we were around
when it was just
dvds mailed to your house so we watched
that
uh we we watched uh that and then uh i
wa i was watching uh serial killer
couples
that [ __ ] was some of the most
disturbing
stories like it's a documentary murder
series that
that [ __ ] was incredible what who
who are these how is this woman out of
jail what is happening right now
oh god and those things about like how
much time they don't spend behind bars
yeah
like is is that's enough to keep you up
all night peter pacheco
trailer re-cuts in the stream man what's
going on
buddies for being going on for the
re-cuts peter pacheco
scary stories to tell in the dark the
witches monsters hellions
scary stories to tell in the dark is i
feel like that's really flown under the
radar that was a really
i we really liked that movie yeah i
thought it it did a nice
anything about a sequel ever anything
about sequels for that
i haven't either uh and i feel like it
did modestly
all right i mean i feel like it did as
well as goosebumps
yeah you know and goosebumps got a
sequel and that movie had a lot of cg in
it yeah
the sony animation team behind it
partially so
i don't know but i would i frankly would
love to see a scary stories too
more than the already existing
goosebumps i feel like the witches got
very lucky that the hbo max streaming
service exists because if it came out of
the theaters i think it would flop
i really do uh yeah actually the kind of
movie that i think would flop but to
have the witches
on hbo max people at least like let me
try it out you know and like let's put
it on for halloween you know weekenders
yeah
exactly exactly and i mean i do i do
sincerely hope in that movie's favor
that they can make something pretty
great because just like family
horror isn't is something that i think
is valuable and underserved so
yeah all right guys so we're gonna start
wrapping up this live stream which means
we're gonna be here for a little while
which means we're gonna refresh
everything we're gonna
refresh everything and uh we're gonna
but please thank you to everyone who's
been like contributing to where it's
always like
overwhelming you know like we all
before every live stream like the little
behind the scenes we'll let you in on
right here
before every live stream we always say
like hey it doesn't
it was usually shorter than this but i
say
it doesn't matter if like we don't get
any like super chats or whatever let's
just entertain these guys and just have
a good time
it's literally the mantra before every
live stream
and then so it's always very flattering
and overwhelming
uh when whenever this we get this many
that makes us go well man we want to rap
by 7 25.
we're a little bit behind now um it's
overwhelming to that extent at the same
time though it's
we're incredibly grateful for it so to
everyone has contributed so far
really thank you uh we're going to ask
that no more for tonight because we're
going to wrap up the last that have
already been submitted because we're
already behind on that so i really
so we're going to we're going to read
through some more right now this doesn't
mean raining right now we're not ending
we're not
relaxed it's not done we want to make
that clear some people think we're like
leaving
when it's not done we're just gonna do
the last of this
of the questions from uh stream labs and
the super chats we're preparing
we're not leaving we're not leaving
right now yeah you know we got
business to handle still stay around
please please we're just gonna
i'm just saying there's a reason we were
asking for uh
uh whoever was thinking of contributing
some more please don't
because we wanna we're gonna wrap this
up goodnight sylvester
sylvester good night to everyone else
who's leaving right now but see all
these people are saying but i don't want
them to think we're
you know don't worry you know what i
mean i feel like i miscommunicated that
it's communicated poorly they're so
great poorly they're a communicator i
know
which is actually i think probably true
i'm surprised this is the first time i'm
being asked this question
hitman hudson i'm really surprised right
after i said that niraj
it's a pledge right yeah
oh but he had to explain it i get it
[Laughter]
i don't want to jump ahead to super
chats but now i really want to see that
movie anyway
hey man i'm surprised is the first time
he's asking this i have returned
cast a biopic about the real rejects
please also how does greg know
uh how does greg know uh
justin um uh what's uh justin russo
david henry well um i
the real rejects who would play us well
obviously i would be played
we would be played by the two greatest
underrated white actors
thomas jane and guy pierce pierce
yeah and then you know olivia will be
played by jeffrey dean morgan yeah other
underrated guy actor we got it covered
perfect we'll recast all of the
characters regardless of race and gender
with underrated white guy actors
those are the picks undoubtedly they
earned it after today
i just think that it's about time we go
back to whitewashing all right
that's what i'm saying yeah we've tried
this diversity thing with me
you know wipe me up parasite won the
oscar and everybody who's not white won
the emmys
so now we're done with diversity we did
it
how do and we we both know david well we
met david at the same time eighth grade
and
john was actually close with david
initially yes
yes before you started i stepped in i
and then david uh but no yeah like the
dave and i remain close for
for several years after that and like we
were always like
i've actually i've been watching boy
meets world with olivia
which is so good
so good this is my first time watching
boys world
okay i i saw the final
episode of boy meets world and that was
it like
when it first aired on television okay
it's
and i don't remember it i just remember
like they're talking with mr feeny at
the end that's all i remember
so olivia's it's one of her favorite
shows his boy meets world so i was like
let's watch boy meets world
it is we're on season three now it is
hilarious
has such a great heart great less like
there are times like wow
there is so much nuance in this episode
it's a great show now you're making me
want to watch it and the portrayal
how i would describe um the way i felt
with david henry's fam
with the henry's was the way how
in season two at the end of season two
how sean
is being cared for by corey's family
and i wasn't like sean but the way how
they cared for
him and someone who grew up with a tough
life that's how david henry's family was
with me
so i have this constant feeling of
always feeling grateful
for the experience i had with the family
and always feeling like i'm in debt
so whenever they wanted when david like
was like hey you know i'm thinking of
doing this
for uh mind if i come on a promote the
channel promote this on your channel
immediately like dude whatever the hell
you want you know like you've
helped me out so much in my life yeah
uh but yeah topanga was so hot i'm sure
she's still hot today
boy miss world is not boring who said
that
was lit and hitman has also says most
overrated moot film of the past decade
and why is it safety not guaranteed
i don't i don't know why just watch
safety not guaranteed and it has
outstanding it's overrated
has an ounce it's underrated premise
with a truly mediocre execution also am
i a bad person for having never before
seen the nightmare before christmas
nah man i only saw the nightmare before
christmas like two years ago
for the first time and i i personally am
a fan
of the take that you know hey you've not
seen this classic thing
that's really exciting because you get
to experience it for the first time i
wish i could do that again
you know so so i'm excited for you
safety not guaranteed i think is is the
overrated film of the decade
only because it launched colin trevorrow
to like
shepherding star wars and jurassic park
very true out of nowhere and i liked
safety not guaranteed fine enough but
i wasn't like give this man hollywood
yeah you know
after that do you never lose your nerd
gotta meet topanga no way
oh dude no way never lose meeting
but dude don't feel bad about not having
watched nightmare before christmas i get
it
kind of becomes part of your identity
that's the only reason i haven't seen
shawshank
and forrest gump and why i haven't seen
blade i've kind of gotten addicted to
the
the
yeah tom hanks sweet nan nan thanks for
being here
my sweetie yeah you changed your name
it's awesome
unless you're a whole new person who's
also nan i'm non-binary
and trying out some new names to see if
they fit these so
my nick my chan my name might change
before tonight
is that what she said he said non-binary
what they said they said
thank god thank god you're here to sign
me on that can't tell if it's a typo or
something i haven't said it before
i wish i could just say the word he and
she at the same time just gotta say that
she has she hissy
hey
but thanks for not being homophobic
dicks oh oh
we work really hard at that it's a lot
of effort
it's a lot of effort to not let's
destroy
this well-wish right on the spot
yeah hey i mean no no problem at all
literally
because no problem always affected our
lives
yeah i and i well honestly i do know
from from knowing enough people i know
that any community but also the film
community can be exclusionary
and and you know uh keep people out the
reason we're being sarcastic about that
is because
it just makes no sense but homophobia
and racism just doesn't make sense to me
and so i'm like it's not hard to not be
either of those guys oh dude
in fact this isn't this isn't some great
uh uh
you know a testament to my tolerance or
whatever but last night i watched
a couple very fascinating documentaries
about uh the drag scene
one from the 60s and one from the 90s
one was called the queen
it was fascinating stuff like in the
energy i don't know why
yeah it just made me think of that well
yeah well i watched brokeback mountain
i haven't seen it i watched brokeback
mountain proven to myself i watched it
by myself
and i and i didn't turn
which is basically just us going like
it's it's
it's always really uh affirming and
really i don't know it's very nice to be
thanked for something like that but also
then you think about yourself and you're
like
but i'm not the greatest person in the
world i'm sure that i'm ignorant in
certain
ways that i could be better about um but
yeah seriously like
welcome like i don't know now i'm
thinking way too hard about what i'm
saying but
like yeah you've had some bad
experiences in movie and tabletop
uh spaces in real life and it's
refreshing not to deal with it i'm
really
happy to hear that because you know if
there's there's
yeah if there's any place that we should
all get together and celebrate like film
is is is so diverse like it's
it's such a diverse art form literally
fashioned out of a diverse range of
skills and experiences and so yeah i'm
really happy if you can find some
comfort
here you know in this little bubble with
us yeah look
we accept everyone all right unless
you're a white supremacist
yes wow look how easy that was to say
those words
well i almost missed it it was so quick
that's the only type of people we all
wanted
yeah intolerance shouldn't have a home
here with the reject nation so that's
all i'll say
yeah no seriously seriously thank you
for being thank you for uh
saying that and um i hope to keep
entertaining you and yeah you're
absolutely accepted yeah and hey let us
know which name
you ultimately decide to stick with
well you should stick with sweden i mean
sweden and nan is just a great name
across the board
how could you change it from here get
your identity
changed to just sweet nan all one name
you know be like a synonymous thank you
sweden seriously thank you though that
means a lot
um tongue punch fart box
i can't react to the trailer for the uh
documentary because i've already seen
the documentary and it's
really good it's really i put out a
tweet about that
it's really good oh yeah no we we lost
people the second i said that white
supremacy don't worry darth yo
i i saw that happen right away oh
i'm always surprised when they're here
but that's that's my point though
that's my point because if someone had
said that
they might have lost some followers and
i'm okay
with not having those followers
yep that's the difference believe it or
not
it's okay to not have them follow you
contrary to popular belief the main
motivation for all that we do is not
you like me yeah can't taint that
um can't stay but wanted to contribute
tongue punch fart box thank you so much
deontay
can't stay but just wanted to contribute
i love
dad's silence don't breathe is up there
for me too and also the first
paranormal activity i'm a fan of cheesy
remakes like house of wax
and texas chainsaw 2003 currently
watching the platform with my
fiancee oh now congratulations on your
engagement
congratulations scooter uh dead silence
is a film that jon and i do personally
find to be pretty underrated yeah don't
breathe
underrated stuff by the director and
writers themselves
are they really gonna make uh don't
breathe sequel i heard they're working
on that
he's been talking about it for a while i
mean
i i don't want to see that i only want
to see it's a perfect one off
it is a perfect yeah that's the problem
is i'm like i i just want fetty alvarez
to make another horror movie that's not
like a spider's web you know franchise
installment or whatever
so i'll take it but also i'd rather he
just i don't know do something fresh
i i remember i saw um
i i saw we we freddie alvarez
like retweeted our trailer reaction
tweeted out our trailer reaction yeah
and then we
we went to a we we met him at uh i think
it was just
like an actual movie screening he was or
something it was it wasn't like a
like a press screening it was an actual
screening for like
we paid to go see the movie hat and then
uh he would happen to be there and uh he
recognized
i thank you yeah it must have been for
like yeah there's a great feeling the
opening of yeah some
some big horror flick but yeah that that
was one of those like that and the and
the uh
logan marshall yeah two of those moments
like oh my god
this guy actually knows these are great
picks thank you tongue punch fartbox
and congrats again on your engagement
yeah will she take on your name
or will you do a hyphenate yeah
and and piss off people who you know
whose opinion you shouldn't take into
account
i love i love seeing so much dead
silence love because that literally is
the film that both
james 1 and leigh 10 are like i don't
really think we did a good job i don't
think we got it right
i'm like guys i think it's great fun
fact that movie was supposed to be pg-13
and it's one of the rare cases where the
studio was like can you make this gorier
really yeah oh good call i love when a
studio knows when our rating is a
good fit yeah
alex wolfe that says dead signs for the
win all right let's refresh this
johnny help me out here let's refresh
this oh yeah just going through the last
of the super chats and stuff
just making sure we don't miss nobody
thank you to everyone for being here
keep listening some more horror movies
you guys recommend in the chat
oh goodness all right so that was the
last of the stream i appreciate that
appreciate that appreciate you okay did
i miss any from my
list of of horror films i don't think so
okay john no i'm i'm i'm good we're good
good
all right we got it we got it we got all
right just a few more left
we got sarah campbell a few more left
let's go out strong john
john help me out here is that how you do
it i did it dude
you you are me thanks for this crunchy
you're
that's all it takes man it's got my juju
on it
sarah campbell thank you sarah i just
joined
the live stream so i don't know what's
going on
and and by the time we're reading this
now it must have at least been 10
minutes so
i don't know when you joined but uh
thank you i just joined the live stream
so i don't know what's going on but i
wanted to say hi halloween is my
birthday
so i like to think i'm spooky by nature
what a great time to be
born that is the dream right there happy
early birthday happy month of a birthday
when you came out of your mom's vagina
did did your dad say
treat treat
there's a much better way to formulate
that joking and i could have set that up
way better staring in trick or treat
what would happen if your mom had
delivered a trick instead
i botched that joke there's there's a
wonderful version
that could have made that a lot better
oh
golly that's a good i don't know what
i'm doing a happy death day is a great
one yes you should watch scream all day
long
by the way man this is your birthday
month
in the way they're all celebrating you
yeah
you are on the veil between which the
living and the dead
traverse between worlds happy birth
happy birthday that's what my greeting
card to you will say
sorry the funny thing is i'll make a
joke
or i'll say something outlandish from
time to time
and then th the live stream there's a
delay
so the live stream will hear that joke
like
30 to 90 seconds later and then
then i'll see comments much later after
i've already moved on from the top
okay that's the way though that keeps
things interesting
also if sweet and anand's still in the
chat i just want to see what the
progress of your name is so if you're
here let us know
um then why are you guys face bombing
each other guys guys guys there's a
beautiful joke guys what made it work
was that it was a bad
face face smile and laugh
but thank you sarah campbell eric
horseman shout out to my fam anissa
bradley busy doing a haunted house mark
console also to greg john and olivia
thank you so much eric you are one of
the
core members like if there was an inner
circle of
core members of the real region of the
reject nation
this was like an eyes wide there was a
council of the reject nation
you would you would be it you would be
the head of our supreme court
not make it a political i'm just saying
if there was a supreme court justice
system with the reject nation
you would be one of the heads
undoubtedly i would love to see eric
in a judicial setting um
mama's geeky oh she gave us a bird
what does it say it's a fist
ah fist bump dude happy birds thank you
mama's geeky seriously she's got a great
reaction channel go check her out
there's a reason she's got 50k subs she
kills it over there
puts a lot of hard work in murders it
murders it
never subscribed or seen one of her
videos so i don't know what the hell i'm
talking about
i'm just joking
uh go check her out seriously she does
an amazing job amazing job
she just retracted a message yeah she
did that was the that was a [ __ ] you
that's what it was right there [ __ ] you
i didn't mean to send that and
something about blind manor
[Laughter]
sarah campbell okay i guess we're but
thank you uh
thank you mama's geeky for that uh sarah
campbell
okay i guess we're talking about
underrated horror movies oops well my
pick is identity with john cusack great
call
yeah james mangle joint right there you
know when i saw identity
i was at the very front row to the far
right yeah very front row far right
that's how i saw cloverfield
so it was like this for me to watch the
movie it was like right up there
and everyone shaped like a cone but but
crooked
and then there was some woman who was
scared the whole time and was
shaking her legs obnoxiously
it annoyed me it sounds like
so i cut her head out like a rough
experience that day
but she did she had it it was annoying
but you know the person's scared i can't
complain it's like when we i saw evil
dead one with a friend and
she was like freaking out the whole time
and then someone in
behind us was like can you cut it out
i'm like it's a horror movie
so even though i was like annoyed with
the woman like just who
she was like she was making my chair
rumble the whole time
yeah i was like it's a horror she's
scared
like i'm not gonna be like hey quit
feeling the feelings that the movie
wants you to feel
you know yeah like go into a comedy be
like stop laughing so loud
it's like someone was like crying in
titanic and i'd be like could you
cut the [ __ ] all right i'm trying to
watch the movie this this literally
reminds me of our endgame screening
because we did have one of those moments
where i think a lot of us were in the
crowd going someone is crying a bit
too hard but yeah you know
it's fine that's what the movie wants
you know appreciate that sarah campbell
yeah eric horseman
one last chat cause i love you i love
you too eric we're probably gonna cover
a show just to keep you happy
shout out to the emotes i mean this
guy's getting
so much you are like every single
weekend and patreon and more and got a
tattoo i'm like i feel like we owe him a
show
when when we get to this point we're
gonna have like a special
brick made with your name on it and it's
just gonna like be the corner brick of
the office or something
you know a big part of like youtubing is
having to deal with
the pressure of feeling like you got a
people please and given to every [ __ ]
request right
and learning to manage expectations and
manage meeting requirements like that
but i feel like eric has sort of
exceeded a certain point
but really we kind of have to just give
it to him at this point we've lost so
much
track that yeah i'm pretty sure we owe
you at this point for the rest of time
especially if you keep this up we'll
never catch up
i'll just react to anything man whatever
you want just tell me
but thank you buddy and yes olivia is
the most beautiful amazing woman in the
world
love the [ __ ] out of her um she's so
funny she just cracks me up
she's so honest she is an honest one
she's so honest uh
the alpha santos love that that's my
mom's maiden name
santos this is your mom's superhero it's
my mom
gregory
what do you want from trader joe's
it's okay it's like she's here uh how do
you all feel about 28 days and weeks
later well you might have caught my 28
days later
story in the stream earlier about my mom
catching him i'm putting your last name
santos i'm catching some dick um and
then also 28 weeks later
i thought it was alright you know a lot
of people really love 28 weeks later for
me
i'm not i i've never cared to revisit it
but 28 days later i think it's a
awesome film landmark but 28 weeks later
yeah i was like alright man 28 days
later is a definite horror favor of mine
28 weeks i guess i'll have to see this
much just wanted them to keep the
franchise going so we could get to like
28 000 years later
yeah yeah part five or six is gonna be a
whole other
it's like well we're how many of them
again i'm running out of 28s to do
we're at 28 000 now and then pretty soon
you run out of units of measurement so
it's
28 trillion tetragons later and the
movie is just a spattering of colors
and sounds nothing's intelligible oh
only reason i wanted to keep that
it's just a camera shooting a microscope
at that point we've made it close to the
end the last three
niraj krishnan who explains as john did
a great improv session
trying to explain house number 13. let's
see how right i was
what was your basic plot about oh it's
about this realtor who's about to sell
his last
house and it's uh the 13th one that he
built but no one wants to buy it because
that's unlucky so then he has to like
strong arm and torture people until he
finds someone to take the
house so let's see what naraj said house
number 13 is a horror comedy about an
indian movie crew stuck in a haunted
house in england and there is a language
barrier between the ghosts and the crew
that sounds like a great i want to see
that yeah that sounds like a great
awesome
i love that you just you can see it
you're like why would you
write that out you could see it you can
that's a great elevator pitch too
like you can see it yeah i can feel the
comedy already
it's like immediately like oh kind of
like what we do in the shadows i mean
it's christopher guest
you know something like for your
consideration yep i'm writing it down
literally on paper that's a great one
narage
mirage way to salvage you got
interesting tastes my dude and
and also thanks for the music that you
send as well
never lose your thank you niraj never
lose your nerd
do you all like the descent i love that
movie yeah we do
yeah it's a great movie we do never lose
your nerves it's a terrific yeah we do
buddy
that's a good it's yes it's good it's
good you know the first 40 minutes
you're like is this even a horror movie
they're just
cave diving it's like an actual movie
yeah it's [ __ ] i feel like there's not
even
character development like strong women
before being strong women was a really
thing
romero sanchez the others that is a
definite favorite of mine yeah fantastic
plot twist did you know did you know
oh we blinked dude i know we believe
that so that's what [ __ ] up the free
stream but we
felt it yeah we never consulted
everyone
it's all right as long as we broke we
broke together but the others
um tom cruise and nicole kim were
married when they were making it and he
produced it and then they got
a divorce and then he still went and
promoted the film
after they were divorced because he also
produced a profit
yes is rick and morty back um
so yeah oh man that's delightful uh but
yeah the others is a great film thank
you romero sanchez thank you for the
contribution you know who else is in the
others
little christopher eccleston who's also
in
uh the 28 days later yeah um
and then we got a couple last two super
chats to end the night off with boom
strongly strong if noah will be really
impressive strong women will be really
impressive
we like going here
john help me out here buddy oh yeah we
doing this we're doing it
okay you got it your perf your your
money you're so much money baby you're
so
oh wait no but then but then darth yoda
just gave one
we got we want your names to shine on
screen dude
we want to make sure you're being
highlighted here dude
john ah oh no they'll see behind the
curtain they'll see they'll see what the
true nature of this operation is
let's see yeah this is what a youtube
video manager section is
they'll see that there's information to
access
why do we have the bill and ted title
png still we're ruining the illusion
all right last three thank you brandon
brandon3
thank you brandon can you guys both be
cowboys for halloween
well okay if we were to be jake
gyllenhaal heath ledger which one would
you be
uh maybe enos because i gotta call it
ernest
i claimed it okay fine then the wait
which one's enos though is that
heath legend heath ledger he calls him
enos so you must be eating his so i have
to be jake jones put it on then
as beautiful as that film is come on
even that author had to know like what a
name it means
last name enos yeah i think your dean is
am i getting that wrong no it's enos i
think it's
i think i believe i mean double check it
out i think it's an enus or something
like that i don't know i've always
wanted to be a gritty cowboy so maybe
enos which is which is which is how
which you know
has the obvious rhyme but also you
switch one letter and you also have you
know an anus so there you go
yeah that's that's why oh you didn't
think penis
oh yeah i was just i was thinking it
sounds like anus
it sounds like anus but also it's just
it's also painful
[ __ ] they were thinking i didn't even
think about penises
well now you are now we all are
[ __ ] oh man
anyhow uh and now and you're not saying
babies one day we will be cowboys for
all it's
only only for your cowboy fetish we have
this
kingsman but yeah okay it's perhaps n is
but [ __ ] oh so it is more like pen
penis or it's more like how great
pronounced being a penis but
it was more like petnus
doesn't
i've seen he has like he seems to
swallow and have a lot of very guttural
like a lot of his
dialogue is spoken kind of towards the
back of his throat he's kind of like
compilations with jensen and jared and
stephen amell oh that sounds like
a great time honestly deontay okay i'm
back the platform is pretty good what
more
horror movies do you think you could
survive thank you deonte
uh what hormones do you think you could
survive all the ones where the
character lives at the end uh i could
definitely survive
nightmare on elm street but by just not
sleeping by just editing a lot
i would just be like [ __ ] i'm committed
i'm gonna kill myself right now i gotta
sleep eventually
um i mean i win you don't get me
does it count like could i say the ring
because i know i can just copy the tape
wait yeah which one do you place
which one is tango and which one is cash
broke just search broke back yeah broke
back
i'm totally spelling this wrong guys
it's okay
broke back jake gyllenhaal is the
character in his broke bag
and his dominance and is still mar okay
but okay but
he says it is anus all right yeah yeah
um but yeah
that's how i would play my nightmare on
all street world john
any any living one is what you said um
what horror movie could i make it
through
um uh let's see happy death day
hey that's a good call it's a great call
man that's a great call
smart move smart maneuver dude at a thin
air moment
that would be fun ryan beatty rosie
beatty sorry
awesome my fart it's okay you know
what's funny
it said darth yoda066 and then i was
like i was thinking
rosie beatty right don't do the
what what's that called when you like
when the name
calling what's the what's the term
i'm forgetting the term not i don't know
what it is for somebody's chosen name
but you mean like the equivalent of like
misgendering somebody or something like
that
yeah yeah i forget it uh mis
name whatever it doesn't matter all
right sorry rosie baby
yeah because i was like oh yeah it's
been a while since we've seen that super
chat from rosie
darth yoda and then i was like oh rosie
and then for some reason my subconscious
went back to
i used to term for that i want to make
sure i'm getting the terminology right
out of respect
i'm not 100 sure i mean this is the
message you personally rosie this is the
first time yeah in a while that i've
just seen darth yoda because usually
it's all
usually it's one big long kind of like
readout on patreon this is how you
recover right
as i recover
[Music]
everybody slips and it's how you get
back up to count
she gets me dead navy that's what it is
greg and john you guys make this channel
a safe place for those who are lgbtq
plus people okay even though i [ __ ]
that up thanks for being awesome
also american werewolf i mean
my timing could not have been more
exceptional
you know it's live things happen yeah
you know and
and and hey i mean that's part of i
think the love that we've been able to
cultivate is that you know even when
something like that slips i think yes
it's clear that we don't
mean it hatefully yeah exactly you see
she gets me
thank you rosie for understanding that's
actually that's actually good for me to
know because uh
i've heard the the term before and not
fully connected
yes so that's what it is so yeah i'm
glad i know now
but but i know better and i caught
myself
oh thank god rosie forgives me for
everything um but yeah no
of course i mean i've i've this is the
first time i i think we've ever been
like
here here twice been brought up in our
stream i mean i'm kind of
it was the first time i've ever been
pointed out for that but like
to us it's it's not really a it's weird
because to us it's not like a conscious
choice of just letting accepting and not
judging people's choices it's
a silly concept to to attack people or
judge people before i know it happens
you know it's a real thing that you know
a lot of people who are not us have to
deal with
and have to deal with this unfair
criticism and and hate
uh which i know can lead to a lot of
really dark depressing feelings at the
same time
it leads to a lot of building a strong
character so so
yeah i mean to me it's not something i
really comment on
because for i'm also like well i just
have never
felt like i have to work to
[Music]
accept someone you know well yeah and i
don't know i mean
i i i feel i guess but i get it because
we have friends who are transgender we
have friends who are
uh homosexual so we've had friends from
all walks over the years and
i don't know i mean the older i get and
i've felt this way for a long time but
truly and honestly and i i feel i guess
a little bit like uh like okay
buddy like in saying this but like i
don't know one of the things in life
that makes me
feel good is seeing people of all
different stripes
thrive and and you know get to express
and share stories and stuff like that
and i feel like especially what we
congregate around here you know like
movies and and popular media and stuff
like that those things are
or should be for everyone to take in and
interact with and enjoy and so yeah it
just feels like a natural part of how
things are supposed to be
exactly um you know and yeah it's like
that really well john
there's so many kinds of people and i
feel like that's what makes life special
so
thank you i'm glad that you guys feel
that way and thank you all for
being here because that means that that
means a lot just as like a human to hear
that but seriously even though we're
wrapping up in a minute next week
underrated white male actors underrated
straight straight i don't want any
any confusion let's just do the cis
white male underrated actors
only with beards gotta ease the
complimentary
sincerity tension here really yeah
kids are sincere and then the last one
of course
eric horseman yes thank you i love i
love how it's
you guys are the last t what are you
doing you're
i love how you guys are the last two
just love you guys also my step
kids anissa and bradley oh well thank
you so much
eric love you too um
yeah buddy i love you it's a nice
mixture of emotions that also went to
a really sweet instance here this has
been a great time thank you eric
thank you to everyone who contributed
today i think that's the thing is the
second somebody points something like
that out you're immediately like
am i gonna become a bad person this is
gonna like respond receive this and
say something's stupid am i gonna makes
me look like a liar am i gonna
trip over my one most egregious latent
piece of ignorance right now
but yeah anyway guys this has been a
really fun stream
last night great thank you everyone who
contributed our way was
really loose yeah interactive thanks for
sharing your halloween flicks like it's
fun
even though we can't like be outside
doing haunts and stuff like it's fun to
congregate with everybody and get in the
spirit this way a lot of great picks
and i'll end this with one i never
mentioned
creep show watch creep show creep show's
great
um and lana pico is saying eric horseman
is
every only fans girls dream customers
that's that is a very accurate
assessment that is
that is the best thing i've heard today
i think oh bye maria hammond
oh marie we are here oh wow maria
hi maria i love you maria be safe bye
sylvester
bye tm bye eric all is love and uh
supernatural shirts we got from anisso
libous you're gonna have to ask her
judas tm oh so many people guys love all
of you
thank you so much for being here this is
seriously great
john love thanks for being here hey
anytime buddy
mom is geeky of course mama's geeky
thanks for sponsoring the stream
erica sylvester erica darth yoda mimi
god joel jesus venice candyman
thomas james thomas jane jeffrey dean
morgan
all right otherwise mr bahu all right
we'll see you guys soon
bye